[Musique]
Jean-Jacques Tisler, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Alors brièvement, oui, je suis donc je
suis psychiatre, psychanalyste
et médecin directeur de ce qu'on appelle
un CMPP,
centre médico psychopédagogique.
Donc c'est de la pédopsychiatrie. Dans
chaque arrondissement de Paris, il y a
une unité comme ça qui est dédiée au aux
enfants depuis disons 2 ans jusqu'à 20
ans quand même. Et à l'intérieur de
cette activité
de soutien aux enfants, aux jeunes, aux
adolescents, on a développé depuis une
dizaine d'années, je crois que c'est
pour ça que vous m'invitez,
un accueil spécifique pour les réfugiés
demandeurs d'asile.
Euh voilà,
on vous a invité pas que pour ça, mais
c'est surtout un sujet qui nous tient à
cœur
surtout à propos de ça. Oui.
Ouais. C'est c'est
mais on nous on a une activité plus
vaste évidemment que le que la seule
mais bon ça nous a pris un non seulement
du temps mais en plus un ça nous a donné
une âme un peu hautre effectivement
depuis.
Pourquoi vous dites âme ?
Bah ça nous a, si je puis dire, en
prenant unogiste, ça nous a amé quelque
sorte, c'est-à-dire ça nous a ça nous a
parce que ça nous a
on peut pas on peut pas s'occuper des
enfants et des parents quand quand il y
a encore des parents parce que bon, on
peut pas s'occuper de cette clinique de
l'exil et de la demande d'asile sans
sans être remué soi-même très
profondément.
Moi, moi j'ai 68 ans là comme je vous
disais, donc j'ai un peu d'expérience
quand même, des choses parfois lourdes
mais
ce genre ce genre de clinique, ce genre
de rencontre, ça nous a bousculé.
C'est combien d'études de psychiatre ?
Alors, psychiatrie, il faut faire 7 ans
de médecine générale plus 4 ans
derrière.
Vous venez de dire j'ai j'ai une
certaine expérience. Est-ce que cette
expérience vous anesthésie ?
C'est c'est une belle question ça. Ça
pourrait ça pourrait dans certains cas
euh Oui, on peut prendre on peut prendre
des habitudes, des stéréotypes, des
façons de penser. Oui, ça peut ça peut.
Et moi, j'ai la chance j'ai la chance de
partager mon temps comme je suis
psychanalyste en cabinet privé, bon mais
en institution c'est on a une équipe.
Faut bien gagner sa vie, c'est ça ? Non,
pas que. En équipe. En équipe, on est
bousculé par les collègues, par les
jeunes collègues. On reçoit des
stagiaires, des étudiants, voyez. Donc
on a on n pas le temps de s dibanter
trop c'estàd
donc on a décidé de vous de vous faire
venir pour aborder ce sujet de des
séqueles psychologique et et
psychiatrique chez chez le réfugié, chez
le gamin, chez chez chez les gens qui
sont dans la rue,
mais aussi sur la société, votre regard
sur la société, comment ça se passe,
comment vous percevez les choses,
comment les gens, nos politiques ou pas
nos politiques, nos journalistes ou pas
nos journalistes s'expriment, qui prend
le contrôle dialectique, qui utilise
quel type de sémantique pour aller où,
vers qui, vers quoi ? À l'heure
actuelle, c'est la guerre avec euh la
Russie. Euh l'Ukraine euh est en guerre.
La Russie est en guerre, l'Europe est en
guerre malgré euh toute la rétorique du
fait que nous ne sommes pas en guerre
pour l'instant, mais euh
ça y ressemble quand même beaucoup.
Comment vous en tant que TBI bib, en
tant que psychiatre, en tant que
psychanalyste,
vous percevez le climat ambiant ?
Comment vous percevez la communication
autour des violences autour des
migrants, des violences autour de la
guerre ? Allez-y, vous avez carte
blanche.
Bah, je dirais dans un premier Attends,
excusez-moi, on va aussi parler des
séqueles, du Covid, du confinement, de
comment ça se passe et tout ça. On peut
élargir comme vous souhaitez bien sûr.
Oui.
Non, je dirais que la période elle-même
qu'on qu'on traverse là, qui a commencé
par le Covid effectivement, mais qui s
il s'est vu greffer,
il s'est vu greffer ces questions de
guerre au passage et c'est énorme pour
les enfants, les jeunes, tout le
désordre climatique annoncé.
Et alors ça ça pèse ça pèse terriblement
sur la jeune génération
et et en je dirais de manière la
continue ces questions de migration
tellement polémiqué et qui néanmoins
vont pas cesser évidemment de se
produire.
La solastalgie c'est ça
on peut dire.
Et alors ça, je dirais qu'on a on a eu
affaire à moi ce que ce que j'ai appelé,
mais je suis pas le seul hein, une un
climat un climat euh que les que les
jeunes racontent très bien d'incertitude
généralisée sur le destin,
c'est-à-dire c'est le destin comme tel
qui tout d'un coup est est frappé d'une
incertitude générale, c'est-à-dire ce
qui ce qui paraît pour pour ma
génération, peut-être même pour la
vôtre, assez assez étonnant,
c'est-à-dire dire au même âge au même
âge nous à moi je venais dire à 15 20
ans, moi je doutais de rien pour mon
avenir. Enfin tout m'était ouvert.
C'est les hormones, c'est normal.
Non, je disais tiens j'ai envie de faire
médecine parce qu'un copain fait
médecine. Bon voilà, on s'inscrit en
médecine et puis ensuite à médecine
c'est un beau métier, on pourra faire un
peu ce qu'on veut. Et maintenant dans
cette classe d'âge, alors surtout chez
l'adolescence hein, il y a une espèce
d'incertitude d'angoisse généralisé du
destin.
Que va être le destin ? Donc là, vous
avez raison, il y a il faut faire
presque un diagnostic
psychopathologique. Il y a il y a une
souffrance induite et redoublée parce
que les jeunes apprennent des guerres
aux frontières, des ceci, de cela.
de questions qu'on appelle maintenant
écho écoanxiété liée au à la question
climatique. Est-ce que c'est eux qui
vont le payer ? Et nous bon en partie
mais ça va être pour les suites.
Le fait le fait que cette jeune
génération
soit pratiquement en catatonie
émotionnelle d à des agressions euh de
type de connaissance comme la la prise
de conscience que bah c'est en train de
tourner vinaigre. H
quelles sont les répercussions sur
l'apprentissage, sur le système
cognitif, sur la relation aux autres ?
Quelles sont quelles peuvent être les
répercussions de tout ça ?
Alors non, il y a il y a des
répercussions en pagaille. Il y a des
répercussions en pagaille. C'est-à-dire
que vous avez des phénomènes
entre guillemets un peu nouveaux. Bon,
savoir comment un phénomène est vraiment
nouveau, bon ça reste pour nous une
difficulté, mais vous avez pour l'enfant
pour l'enfant, les petits classe d'âge,
par exemple l'agitation à l'école, on
reçoit on reçoit beaucoup d'enfants
agités comme on dit, ils s'agitent. Il
s'agitent pourquoi ? parce que ils
entendent un enfant petit dès 2 ans dès
2 ans et demi mais il comprend la
totalité de ce qu'il entoure. Il
comprend la totalité des angoisses et de
la dépressivité des adultes qui
l'entourent. Il perçoit il perçoit que
ça va pas. Donc chez l'enfant petit
agitation désordonnée, forme d'angoisse
parfois forme d'agressivité à l'égard de
l'autre. Chez l'enfant qui va qui va
grandir un peu, on va plutôt avoir ce
qu'on appelle le décrochage scolaire
maintenant. C'est-à-dire l'enfant qui
est bon intellectuellement,
qui a tout pour réussir, s'aperçoit que
voilà, il pense à autre chose, il y
croit plus, il fait pas ses devoirs, il
décroche,
il décroche et puis vous avez ensuite
les vraies formes de dépressivité,
c'est-à-dire
et là malheureusement alors nous en
CMPP, on n pas du lourd comme ça, mais
dans les intersecteurs de
pédopsychiatrie déjà tentative de
suicide, des anorexies sévères faire les
addictions bien entendu. Enfin, on a on
a un panel un panel de qui répercute
cette incertitude généralisée avec des
avec des troubles cliniques dont dont
l'État d'ailleurs s'alarme elle-même.
Vous savez que l'État lui-même se dit
mais enfin pourquoi on narrive pas à
suivre les courtes d'enfants ? Mais bon,
vous parlez des des euh l'État n'arrive
pas à suivre. C'est que
non non non mais les ministères s'alarme
en disant mais
il s'arme beaucoup mais il don il s'arme
on pas les moyens on a pas les moyens
derrière donc on a
enfin chaque année il s'alarme on disait
on n pas les on a pas de moyens
supplémentaires derrière quasiment donc
bon c'est une façon de dire
ça c'est lié à la
une espèce de slogan politique comme ça
qui est donné
on on reviendra sur les côtés slogan
politique
ou malheureusement
donc les les conséquences de tout ça
Vous en tant que TBIB, votre équipe,
comment vous faites pour les stabiliser,
leur remettre le pied et leur faire
avoir de de je vais pas dire de l'espoir
? Nous nous on s'occupe beaucoup de
questions.
Et ben si on part de ce que vous avez
dit à la fin, c'està-dire on considère
que quelle que soit la situation,
il faudra ouvrir une lueur d'espoir.
C'est c'est ça le c'est ça l'axiom.
C'està-dire un psi, une psy,
une équipe comme la nôtre. On considère
que quel que soit quelle que soit la
hauteur des dégâts, du traumatisme, de
tout ce que vous voulez, néanmoins notre
seule mission, ça va être d'ouvrir un
horizon, une lueur d'espoir. La chance
clinique qu'on a, c'est que plus
l'enfant est petit, plus il est vrai en
gros que ça marche au prix d'un travail
assez continu avec lui. Ça marche assez
bien. On arrive on arrive à avoir des
bonnes surprises
euh sur le suivi, sur le travail, sur le
transfert comme on dit avec l'enfant.
Plus vous entrez dans des classes d'âge
un peu plus élevée, plus les questions
vont être plus complexes effectivement.
Mais c'est souvent chez chez l'adulte
lui-même que les choses se chronicisent
avec difficulté. Comment vous faites
naître une lueur d'espoir avec un
réchauffement climatique qui est à 3
4°gr en prévision avec
ces mouvements migratoires que ça va
générer avec ses problèmes de de
capacité à faire des récoltes à
s'alimenter
avec la crise énergétique qui va
derrière
alors on ne répond non on peut pas non
c'est-à-dire on peut pas répondre à à
l'ampleur
on ne cherche pas à répondre
rationnellement à l'ampleur des
questions posées. Ça vous avez on les
méconnaît pas non plus, on fait pas
semblant.
Je suis sûr que vous les connaissez pas
correctement.
Non, je vais dire on les on les atténue
pas non plus.
On fait pas semblant que c'est rien,
qu'il y a pas il y a pas à penser mais
on ne on ne cherche pas à répondre à à
l'entièreté.
Non, on se on se cantonne à
des questions qui qui sont plus je
dirais qui sont plus proches de la
psychologie.
euh enfin quotidienne, je dirais,
c'est-à-dire redonner simplement à
l'enfant le goût, le goût des choses,
l'envie des choses, le goût de l'autre,
le goût de l'altérité, le goût de la
rencontre, le goût de la poésie, le goût
de la lecture, le goût voilà enfin le
goût de la vie sans sans lui promettre
que pour autant donc l'univers sera
facile. Ça c'est autre chose. Mais mais
on essaie de recolorer un peu sa vie
fantasmatique comme on dit, sa vie
imaginaire. Voyez
quelle forme ça prend. Ah bah ça peut
prendre des formes tout à fait euh à la
fois tout à fait des fois simples. Vous
savez par exemple les psy enfin les psy
d'enfant s'occupent beaucoup de des un
enfant ça c'est Winicot vous savez
l'inspirateur anglais là de la
psychanalyse de l'enfant ça peut passer
par un dessin au départ un petit vous
recevez un petit dans un état un peu
curieux
c'est quoi un état un peu curieux
non oui c'est vrai c'est bête de dire ça
comme ça un éf un peu stuporeux un peu
apathique un peu il vous regarde à peine
il s'assoit
on prend une feuille on prend des on
prend des couleurs
Et tout d'un coup,
parfois c'est nous qui faisons le
premier trait
et puis l'enfant poursuit. Donc ça c'est
le plus simple. On peut passer par des
choses aussi simples. Moi j'ai toujours
fait, on a toujours eu un par exemple un
atelier poésie et l'enfant tout petit,
assez petit hein et sensible à la
question poétique. Et pour ben ça
faudrait que je m'en explique un peu
plus longtemps tout à l'heure pour même
pour les exilers, on a un atelier
mythologie par exemple. Voyez, on étudie
la haute mythologie
grec
grec alors grec, on a pris la grec
exprès euh parce que comme on avait des
enfants qui venaient du bout du monde de
tous les comp enfin presque avec des
croyances aucun aucun enfant qui nous
arrive et sans croyance ça n'existe pas.
Ils sont pas athés hein. Aucun. Tous des
croyances des grandes spiritualités.
Donc on s'est dit comment comment on
peut les voir ensemble ? Ça vait pas
être on va pas parler de la Bible. Vous
vous avez vous croyez dans un ami
imaginaire aussi ou pas du tout ?
Moi non. Moi non. Mais à force de les
côtoyer petit à petit,
à force de les côtoyer la question le
transfert hein.
Oui. Oui. Non mais à force de côtoyer
ses enfants,
je suis plus sensible aux dimensions de
l'animisme magique à des choses oui
assez bizarrement. C'està-dire avant je
considérais que bon c'est vrai qu'on est
nous dans dans une grande rationalité en
Europe et tout le reste nous intéresse
pas. Je dois dire que à force de voir
des enfants qui trouvent des des sources
vives comme ça dans tous ces imaginaires
collectifs,
il se peut il se peut que moi-même je
sois plus tempéré sur des questions
comme ça.
C'est c'est une se de se préserver
d'avoir un ami imaginaire.
Ah oui, je crois que c'est vraiment une
Moi, j'ai vu même des enf des petits
français entre guillemets là des qui
allaient à l'église pendant le Covid,
ils étaient pas croyants. C'estàd ils
allaient ils allaient chercher une
protection simplement. Ils savaient que
leur il savaient que leurs parents
pouvaient pas se protéger ni les
protéger. Et bizarrement, on voyait des
petits momes elle est à l'église du coin
peut-être pour prier, on sait même pas.
Mais voyez donc ça revient comme ça.
C'est
et donc on a on a saou alors tous les
enfants qui nous viennent du bout du
monde, ils ont ils ont des imaginaires
très forts comme ça. Forme d'animisme
magique
qui pour leur pour leur peuple c'est
normal.
Vous pratiquez la psychiatrie
soviétique, c'est-à-dire avec des
grosses ordonnances de cacheton ou des
choses comme ça ?
Alors nous nous justement non. Nous
justement non. On se fait on se fait une
fierté.
On prescrit très très rarement. Très
très rarement. Alors ça ça au passage ça
c'est une c'est malheureusement une
maladie moderne en pédopsychiatrie. He à
mon à mon époque de formation on ne
donnait jamais de psychotrope à
l'enfant. ça n'existait pas. C'est
interdit parce que on ne sait pas ce que
devient sur un cerveau euh qui continue
à se développer. Euh enfin, les produits
qu'on donne aux adultes, on sait pas.
Enfin, personne ne sait encore
maintenant. Et puis
ça permet de prendre des vacances au
Maldives après derrière. Oui. Oui. Et
alors du coup du coup alors ça c'est
malheureusement, on peut le dire je
pense sans sans se faire trop critiquer,
c'est venu des États-Unis, c'est-à-dire
les États-Unis, la psychiatrie
américaine par côté était très
pharmacologue de
ritaline.
Et voilà donc la ritaline d'un côté,
même les antidépresseurs, les
neuroleptiques sont venus s'associer à
la pédopsychiatrice qui ce qui ce qui je
vous dis il y a quel il y a quelques
temps était presque interdit. Ça
n'existait pas. Alors maintenant, c'est
devenu normal. Alors nous nous dans le
service où où je vis
on fait pas ou à peine ou très rarement.
C'est très intéressant le fait que vous
vous ayez dit où je vis.
C'est vrai. Bah vous savez comment
j'appelle ça ? Enfin j'ai on appelle ça
notre cabane. L'unité où on est là. On a
dit que
on lui a donné ce nom. Une cabane.
C'est là où on se protège.
C'est là où comme en montagne quand vous
trouvez
quand vous êtes perdu dans la neige un
jour.
Par chance, si vous tombez sur un petit
refuge, une cabane, bah vous êtes sauvé.
Sinon, éventuellement, bah non.
Vous votre perception de la situation
actuelle,
vous avez de l'espoir pour la
Vous voulez dire de la la situation
générale.
Ouais. La situation générale en tant que
psy, quand vous voyez par exemple nos
politiques s'exprimer, on reviendra sur
les sujets d'éritaline juste avant. Euh
euh quand vous voyez nos politiques
s'exprimer, quand vous voyez la guerre
débarquer, quand vous voyez les les gens
s'investiver sur les les plateaux télé,
quand vous voyez les diplomates
s'invectivés, vous lui dites "Qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette bande ?" Je vais je
vais être vulgaire si vous me permettez,
docteur. Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
bande de cons avec trois neurones
utilisant uniquement le côté reptilien
de leur cerveau ou vous dites qu'est-ce
que vous dites d'ailleurs ? Non non, moi
j'ai c'est vrai que j'ai un peu une
lecture un peu un peu pessimiste de
l'évolution là du dialogue social
politique
qui n'est pas qui à mon sens est loin
d'être à hauteur des enjeux
euh qui qui sont très très hauts, très
complexes. Et ça fait déjà quel ça fait
déjà là quelques années que j'ai trouvé
que le mais je suis pas le seul que le
que le propos général s'était beaucoup
affessé
et que pour répondre au défis des
réalités là qui nous viennent,
il faudrait se mettre un peu
tranquillement à réfléchir en commun
avant avant que de avant que de se
heurter. Et puis il y a il y a un point
clinique qui m'a qui
me tarde depuis déjà quelques années,
c'est c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle en psychiatrie l'anesthésie
affective,
hein, qui d'habitude était accordée à la
mélanc à la mélancolie,
c'est-à-dire ne plus être affecté
par ce qu'on voit par l'autre.
Et ça ça m'est venu euh
ça m'est venu il y a déjà quelques
années hein. Ça m'est venu il y a
quelques années
euh parce que
quand j'étais enfin plus jeune
quand vous vous promeniez le soir dans
Paris, il y avait des gens dans la rue
mais ces gens étaient étaient pris. Il y
avait des navettes de la police de la
préfecture qui venaient les chercher,
qui leur proposaient. La plupart
acceptait d'être ils allaient dans les
hôpitaux publics,
ils étaient lavés, on leur donnait un
petit sandwich, il restaient la nuit, il
reparta le matin à la maison de
Nanterre, à Nanterre, ils en prenaient
beaucoup. Bon, voyez, il y avait il y
avait donc un un regard social sur le
sur ce qui se passait enfin devant nos
yeux. On laissait pas en principe
en pleine rue, en plein hiver comme ça
des gens ou des familles comme moi. Et
puis un jour là, comme vous avez
observé, il suffit de se promener dans
Paris
à tous les coins de rue là, vous avez
des on se dit maf.
Et alors, je me suis aperçu que sur
nous-même au bout d'un temps, on les
voyait même plus. C'està dire, il y
avait quelque chose, voyez, d'une perte
de la vision mentale,
une perte du tragique. On a perdu cette
relation à ça, ça m'a beaucoup affecté
et je dois dire ça m'est revenu par les
par des amis psy qui venaient de
l'étranger. Vous savez que nous on fait
des colloques internationaux de temps en
temps
qui sont d'ailleurs chiant à mourir
quand c'est retransmé sur internet. Dans
beaucoup de cas, c'est pas terrible,
mais à l'occasion, ça peut être animé.
Mais j'avais des amis que j'aime
beaucoup parce qu'ils vivent des choses
aussi difficiles, les collègues du
Brésil par exemple hein qui venaient.
Bon, les Brésiliens et c'est alors eux
ils adoraient se balader la nuit dans
Paris parce qu'ils pouvaient pas le
faire au Brésil, c'était trop dangereux.
Mais il me disait un jour, ils m'ont dit
"Mais Jean-Jacques, mais tu as vu ce qui
se passe dans J'ai dit mais quoi ? Mais
tu vois pas ? Enfin, comment c'est
possible en France ?
C'est du coup ça m'a fait je me suis dit
mais c'est vrai qu'on s'habitue au pire
on est habitué au pire et après après ça
a été encore maintenant d'ailleurs même
les enfants petits hein vous savez il y
a des enfants petits. Nous on suit
parfois des familles exilées mais ils
sont pas relogés par le sams d'hôtel ils
ont rien et ils sont en pleine rue avec
des petits. J'en profite pour saluer mon
ami du salut social qui m'a initié au au
concept de suradaptation paradoxal. Je
conseille je conseille à à la communauté
d'aller se renseigner sur la
suradaptation paradoxale.
Désolé de vous avoir
Non non non non, je vous en prie.
Revenons, on on va on va encore revenir
en arrière. L'aritaline, la pharmacopée,
la psychiatrie soviétique en France, on
est les rois de la consommation de
cacheton. On en je sais pas si on a les
rois mais on en consomme beaucoup.
Ouais. Et et de plus en plus.
On en consomme de plus en plus.
C'est c'est quoi ? C'est une canne,
c'est une canne de neuroleptique pour
pouvoir continuer à faire fonctionner
cette société qui est de plus en plus
malade.
Il y a une phrase d'un d'un philosopheen
qui dit "Ça ne sert à rien." C'est ce
n'est pas preuve d'être ce n'est pas
preuve de bonne santé d'être très bien
adapté à une société profondément
malade. Est-ce que cette canne de
molécule qu'on prescrit,
on va dire
au bon vouloir des Tobibes, est-ce que
c'est pas une façon de de
faire endurer les bêtes à la besogne, à
cette société qui devient de plus en
plus toxique, à cette façon de vivre qui
vient de plus en plus toxique pour les
hommes, pour le biotope, pour la terre ?
Est-ce que
Oui, c'est c'est comme dirait Marx à
l'époque, c'est un genre d'oplium du
peuple. C'est pas faux.
Et puis et puis alors alors derrière il
y a une espèce de alors c'est aussi ça
c'est de l'idéologie en médecine. Il y a
une conception qui était effectivement
qui existait chez les soviétiques à
l'époque de Pavlov ou chez les
Américains à l'époque de Skyer.
C'était c'était l'idée que tout trouble
psychique est neurologique et
neurodéveloppemental comme on dit. Voyez
? c'estàdire enf de ramener à la
substance elle-même n'importe quel
trouble affectif que sais-je. Alors ça
c'est un truc qui revient en force qui a
toujours existé en psychiatrien qui
était de vouloir ramener à de
l'organique les états d'âmes si vous
voulez toujours. C'est toujours il y a
toujours eu des polémiques là-dessus.
Donc la psychanalyse avec Freud,
heureusement c'est écarté en disant non,
c'est des symptômes, c'est pas des
troubles neurologiques. Mais ça revient
au force cette idéologie que les Russes
aimaient bien, que les certains courants
américains aimaient bien et puis c'est
engouffré derrière l'industrie
enfin de la pharmacie effectivement,
c'est-à-dire
engouffrer derrière. Donc la ritaline
c'est c'est un cas paroxistique.
C'est-à-dire que aux États-Unis, il y a
même des procès maintenant à rebour.
C'est-à-dire il eu tellement de
prescriptions de masse
que les familles au bout de 10 ans
accusent accusent des mauvais. Bon,
évidemment, enfin tout se retourne au
bout d'un temps. Mais donc, il y a il y
a il y a cette idée de couvrir les
troubles de la tension comme on dit, les
les donc l'agitation de l'enfant par de
la pharmacopée. Une fois qu'on a
commencé, faut il faut que ça dure
longtemps en plus. Donc, c'est des
années he de prescription parce qu'on
s'arrêtait forcément. Donc c'est
beaucoup de dépenses, beaucoup d'argent,
beaucoup de pharmacie et sur et souvent
sur des diagnostics
très approximatif.
Moi je dois dire, voyez, j'ai quand même
plus de 20 ans d'exercice dans mon où je
suis dans mon unité, dans ma cabane là
et des donc on a on a reconduit certains
enfants étaient arrivés avec des
ordonnances d'héritaline
donc comme le bras
euh non pas trop mais on les a pas
arrêté. On a dit bon, d'autres collègues
ont pris la responsabilité de le faire.
On va voir. Bon, sur le nombre, pas
beaucoup hein, sur le nombre des très
peu mais bon. Et tel ou tel, alors moi,
j'ai toujours gardé en mémoire ce
j'avais un un enfant comme ça qui était
content d'avoir ce traitement.
Un beau jour, enfin le temps passe, vous
savez, 1 an, 2 ans, il y a toujours sous
traitement.
Comment les Américains appellent la
rétanine ? C'est la molécule de
l'obéissance, c'est ça ?
Oui. Oui, sûrement. Oui, c'est ça.
Alors, on met pas toutes les molécules
dans le même sac. Il y a des trucs qui
sont nécessaires. Il y a des trucs qui a
qui sont plus ou moins nécessaires, bien
entendu, d'autres.
Et alors, un jour cet enfant
il me il me regarde les yeux dans les
yeux, il me dit
"Oui, quand même docteur, c'est normal
qu'on parle jamais de mon père ?" Et
alors, je commence à trembler un peu. Je
dit "Mais pourquoi ?"
Et tout d'un coup, je me suis aperçu que
enfin trop de mémoire, moi-même, je
regarde son père s'était suicidé quand
il était plus petit.
Alors je lui dis non, tu as raison, il
va falloir qu'on en parle.
Bref, cet enfant qui était dit agité,
inattentif à tout, avait sorti une des
grandes questions qu'il tarodait depuis
toujours. On a pu la travailler. Il a
passé, voyez, un moment dépressif un peu
évidemment, un moment que j'ai pas
traité par d'autres molécules he moment
plus à juste titre, plus dépressif et
l'agitation a cessé complètement.
On a donc on avait jamais traité ce
point inaugural. Qu'est-ce que pour
l'esprit que suscite d'un père ? Ça
avait été couvert et puis voilà. Donc on
en arme pagaille des problèmes comme ça,
voyez euh qui est de couvrir par la
pharmacie des des défauts d'attention de
l'enfant et souvent qui sont justifiés
parce que il est pas attentif parce que
il peut pas l'être. peut pas l'être sa
cogite ou bien
il y a quelque chose il y a un trou
traumatique qui fait que
donc voilà c'est enfin c'est un exemple
qui m'a qui m'a bouleversé parce que
c'est l'enfant qui qui m'a rappelé que
c'était moi le docteur quand même que je
ferais bien un peu faire un peu
d'anamnèse.
Vous avez fait une analyse
personnellement ? Ah oui, cé obligé. Je
suis psychanalyste. Donc en principe, un
analyste se doit d'abord de faire une
analyse assz assez longue et puis après
de faire des supervisions de travail.
Enfin, il y a tout un protocole quand
même assez
en France, c'est quand même assez
sérieux. Ça reste parce que l'État ne
donne pas le titre d'analyse, c'est
dédié par les écoles de psychanalyse
elles-mêmes.
Quand vous rentrez chez vous, vous
faites la l'analyse de votre famille ou
des choses comme ça ou comment ça se
passe ? Alors non, j'essaie que non. Et
puis euh
j'essaye.
Oui, j'essae, j'essae, j'essaye. Et puis
mes enfants par chance, il ont eu le
talent de il m'arrête dès que dès que je
dérive trop comme ça.
Mais mais où vous avez raison, c'est
qu'on reste on reste néanmoins psy enfin
nuit et jour quoi. On a du mal à se à se
séparer de ce cette dimension de
l'inconscient qui nous tarot sans cesse.
Oui. Mais avec les nôtres, je dirais
bon, il y a quand même un petit retrait
technique. On essaie de pas trop tout
psychologiser tout de même.
On essae. On essae.
Sautons aucalan. Je vais je vais je vais
un peu essayer de chambouler votre
cerveau même si vous avez été formé pour
résister.
Euh
comment vous percevez la mythomanie
chronique des différents porte-paroles
de différents gouvernements ? Euh c'est
assumé, c'est pas assumé, c'est voulu,
c'est pas voulu. Euh clairement il ils
affiche tous les les symptômes du du
grand mythomane.
Euh vous en tant que tout bib, quand
vous percevez un discours, euh ça vous
fait quoi ? Non, ben on perçoit nous
tout de suite qu'il y a une faiblesse du
discours. Euh, effectivement, on est
quand même habitué à des discours assez
discursifs, dialectiques, un peu un peu
pensé voir disputé au sens classique.
un peu un peu comme les rabins enfin
classiquement où il y en avait toujours
un qui dit comme si puis ah mais non
puis c'est le débat qui fait le
et là et là effectivement là vous avez
raison c'est-à-dire toutes ces
affirmations en pagaille
enfin mégalomaniaque là il y a une
faiblesse épistémologique inouie qui est
évidente. Alors depuis quand exactement
ça s'est aggravé à mon avis encore. Oui
effectivement ça s'est aggravé. Il y
avait peut-être une époque qui était
plus vue. Bon, on a eu quand même des
dirigeants intellectuellement assez
dégourdis. Euh quel
Non, moi je pensais parce que j'étais
militant à l'époque, je pensais à Roard
ou des gens comme ça. Avait
de gauche.
Oui. Voilà. Bon, il y avait quand même
il y avait quand même des discours qui
se tenaient même parfois assez
complexes. Je me rappelle que Rocard
était perçu comme quelqu'un qui était
pas toujours facile à suivre parce que
il était un peu théorique. Enfin bon, il
y avait une pensée. Il y avait une
pensée puis d'autres probablement.
Mais là, mais là vous vous avez enfin
d'un point de vue psy souvent ce qu'on
on est même étonné de que c'est pas des
discours, c'est quasi il y a pas de il y
a pas de discursivité
se heurte à justement.
Quelles peuvent être les séquels sur la
population de ça ?
Bah c'est déjà en cours hein. Je crois
que ça crée ça crée ce dont tout le
monde voilà ce qui est sous nos yeux ça
crée ça crée du ça crée de la ça crée du
désespoir par côté.
On l'avait vécu à l'époque
à l'époque des gilets jaunes, il y avait
c'était symptomatique, c'est-à-dire on
crée on crée chez les gens les moins les
moins protégés du désespoir. Après, on
s'étonne qui à leur façon évidemment.
Bon et là, on l'a on l'a sous nos yeux à
nouveau autrement et ça crée alors le
problème en clinique, c'est connu, hein.
Pour éviter de vous déprimer, là vous
devenez un peu combatif effectivement.
C'estàdire c'est c'est l'agressivité
combative qui supplé à la
mélancolisation.
Donc faut pas s'étonner que quelqu'un a
envie de enfin si je peux dire on va pas
on va pas faire les on va pas dire qu'il
faut donner des coups forcément mais
c'est connu en clinique ça en clinique
la défense la défense un peu sténique
vient supplé à l'effondrement dépressif.
Bon voilà et donc on l'observe làement
forcément
sur le je dirais c'est pas de temps la
bon donc il a la police mais ça la
police ça fait longtemps que il a des
problèmes de maintien de l'ordre qui ont
été analysés depuis 68 là qui posent des
problèmes techniques hein bon on le sait
mais
violences policières vous les analysez
comment
les violences policières vous les
analysez comment
mais je crois je crois qu'ils sont mal
formés moi je dirais moi je dirais
d'abord ça parce que qui est de la
police qui est des militaires qui a des
gendarmes évidemment un pays mais
problème problème, c'est que ça
nécessite des formations
très spécifiques, je veux dire
de résister au stress, de résister à
tout ça,
de résister puis que il y a quand même
une limite une limite dans la
transgression
qui théoriquement peut pas être franchi
sans ordre strict et je crois moi je
pense que ils sont ils sont sous formés
en quelque
ils sont en souffrance aussi peut-être
ils sont en souffrance
ils sont peut-être en souffrance parce
que ils sont effectivement du coup ils
sont mal aimés évidemment il y a une
souffrance
et Puis euh mais je dirais bon ça c'est
une chose euh mais je pense que ce qu'il
fait le plus violent, c'est ce que vous
soulignez, c'est le qu'il n'y ait pas de
de discours social cohérent. C'est ça
qui fait souffrir. C'est ça qui fait
qu'une
donc on le voit, on le voit pour je sais
pas là, on l'a vu pour la polémique là
sur l'eau
et les agriculteurs. Je veux dire,
on peut pas on peut pas expliquer ça en
5 minutes à la vaite qu'il faut le
faire, il faut le faire. enfin général
un truc qui va pas parce qu'il y a pas
de il y a pas au sens plein de discours
donc vous vous heurtez à quelque chose
qui
qui fait désespoir je crois et dans le
et dans dans le pire des cas quand vous
êtes désespéré vous faites une connerie
sur vous-même et sinon bah vous vous en
prenez à l'autre effectivement
c'est une défense c'est une défense
habituelle hein en psychopathologie
c'est connu
est-ce que est-ce que Je sais pas s'il y
a un conseil supérieur des psy. Est-ce
que les psy sont ont essayé d'expliquer
aux politiques que c'était pas comme ça
qu'il fallait s'adresser aux
populations, queils allaient créer plus
de séquel à long terme, à moyen terme et
que vu les fondamentaux qui poussent et
que les trajectoires nous allons quand
même un peu vers le mur, ça allait être
compliqué de pouvoir s'adresser à sa
population sans sans sans avoir
accuré toutes les les les murs qu'on a
créé dans leur tête. Oui. Oui. Non,
est- est-ce que les PS
non, ils sont pas ils sont pas
sollicités là-dessus.
Est-ce que est-ce qu'ils
s'automissionnent en en allant voir les
politiques en disant "Écoutez, nous on
est des professionnels du dialogue. Vous
êtes en train de faire de la merde. Vous
êtes en train de créer des monstres
parce que vous voulez pas assumer.
Est-ce que
Ouais, je crois pas qu' non. Il y a pas
de il y a pas de lieu, voyez, de il y a
pas de lieu de cohabitation des entre
notre profession, je dirais au sens
large et le politique, je pense pas.
C'est-à-dire le politique souvent c'est
comme on disait pour les ils s'alarme
tout d'un coup qu'il y ait toute une
classe d'âge qui soit en désérance et
ils disent mais comment ça se fait que
les petits arrivent pas à tous les voir
c'est tout. Donc il nous pose des
questions complètement et hononté
et dont on prévient par exemple le
manque de psychiatre mais ça fait 10 ans
qu'on en prévient. Donc donc c'est même
pas Macron he c'est connu depuis on sait
bien que ça s'aggrave et que ça va
s'aggraver parce que pour former un
psychiatre comme je vous disais faut 11
ans. Donc c'est pas le jour où on
s'enaperçoit qu'on peut résoudre le
problème
et mais donc la réponse elle est elle
est simplement sur ce mode. C'est-à-dire
ils nous disent il faut vous débrouiller
pour recevoir les souffrances et puis
c'était pour la ligne à budget constant
bien entendu.
Est-ce qu'il y a une évalu psychiatrique
des politiques à partir d'un certain
niveau où il commence à avoir le feu
nucléaire au bout de la main ? Euh
est-ce qu'il y a une évaluation
psychiatrique et même toxicologique
avant de rentrer dans l'Assemblée
nationale ?
Sû je suis pas sûr. Non, je suis pas
sûr. Est-ce
qu'il faudrait leur faire pipi avant de
rentrer dans l'Assemblée nationale ?
Est-ce qu'il faudrait les mettre dans un
bureau une fois par mois pour qu'ils
puissent parler et vider leur sac pour
éviter qu'ils viennent un petit peu
zinzin zinzin avec tout le respect queon
peut avoir avec les zinzins ? Je suis
pas sûr. Bon alors après faut voir par
exemple le service de santé des armées
est très réputé y compris en
psychiatrie. C'estàd à l'armée enfin
dans les armées françaises
la psychopathologie
la psychopathologie générale et même
freudienne est présente c'està-dire
les services de soins en général hein.
Oui. Les services de soins sont
excellents. et la psychiatrie. Moi, j'ai
été une fois pour des raisons
personnelles,
j'avais été comme ça invité à un un
collogue de la psychiatrie militaire.
J'avais été étonné hein, c'était
excellent niveau.
Donc donc il y a il y a il y a des zones
qui où il semble quand même qu'il y a
des réflexions, il y a des il y a des
vraies questions qui se
par exemple enfin non mais c'est juste
une anecdote mais je peux la dire, c'est
pas un secret. J'avais été étonné, ils
avaient fait un débat sur l'utilisation
des drones militaires là parce que parce
que les psychiatres israélien et
américains qui les utilisaient déjà
avaient raconté que ça fabriquait des
névroses traumatiques chez ceux qui
servaient les drones.
Et donc les psychiatres français avant
avant que l'armée achète les mêmes
drones là ce qu' ce qu'ils ont fait
depuis ça était un peu embêté de savoir
comment faire avec ces pathologies
nouvelles
des servants de drone comme ça tueur là
voyez donc
c'est manifestait comment
ah des vrais névroses traumatiques bah
parce que le gars il est dans le Nevada
et maintenant c'est comme ici
c'est-à-dire il voit il voit qu'il va
tuer quasiment à 1 m c'est-à-dire il tue
en Afghanistan ou que sais-je, n'importe
où. Et il voit il voit comme s'il était
à 1 m 1 m de la cible.
Ils sont trois. Ils sont au moins trois
pour servir un drone comme ça.
Et ensuite le gars, il est dans le
Nevada, il vient de tuer une coorte
d'enfants par hasard ou que sais-je,
mais ensuite il fait quoi ? Bah, il va
retrouver ses enfants à la piscine le
même militaire. Et c'est là où se
déclenche en lui un truc qui est pas
gérable. C'estàd donc il y a un passage
sans délai, voyez,
un truc énorme et puis bon alors on vit
on vit tranquillement 5 minutes plus
tard. Donc donc voyez c'est alors ça
dans dans ces univers là, je me suis
aperçu que c'était c'était travaillé.
C'est-à-dire, il y avait une
cohabitation entre la réflexion des
milit bon des enfin des militaires qui
sont des soldats et et des médecins, des
psychologues et lors d'autant que
maintenant euh
les troupes sont accompagnées, vous
savez, ils accompagnent les troupes sur
le terrain
enfin les enfin le service de santé.
Heureusement.
Non, non, mais je veux dire mais c'est
assez c'est assez récent. Donc du coup
il donc non non c'est pour dire qu' il y
a moyen il y a moyen
à la limite sils avaient plus de
psychologues dans la police peut-être
qu'on en serait pas là effectivement
donc il y a moyen d'accompagner les
métiers y compris dans des dans des
choses difficiles voyez qui sont parfois
vous vous avez vu certaines vidéos de de
violence policière ou pas du tout
je les ai pas regardé non je les ai pas
regardé
il y a comme je vais pas dire une une
espèce de forme de jouissance
Oui oui
quand par exemple je reprends de tête
une vidéo des gilets jaunes où il y a un
policier qui tire au LBD 40 armes de
guerre sur des manifestants et qui dit à
voter
c'est c'est une certaine forme une forme
de jouissance bien sûr ou
bah il y a une forme de jouissance
sadique
bah je crois que c'est ça le problème.
C'est-à-dire comme on le sait, s'il y a
pas une déontologie de ses métiers, un
soldat en principe a une déontologie, on
peut pas on peut pas tuer n'importe
comment.
Ça dépend quel type d'armée, hein.
Oui, mais dans le meilleur des cas, il
principe une diontologie, on tue pas
l'enfant de 2 ans qu'on va rencontrer au
passage. En principe, non,
on tire pas sur les hôpitaux.
On tire pas sur les hôpitaux, on pas se
cacher dans les hôpitaux.
Voilà. Si c'est si c'est un blessé, on
va pas l'achever pour rien. Si on peut
quand même le sauant. Bref,
donc c'est pareil, c'est pareil en
principe dans les forces de l'ordre.
Mais quand quand ça s'est dépassé,
transgressé, effectivement on rentre on
rentre dans une jouissance mortelle.
Oui, mortifère, vous avez raison.
C'est pour ça qu' à mon sens c'est un
défaut de formation je pense un défaut
de formation technique et psychologique.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire ? Bah
comme ils ont fait à l'armée, avoir une
cororte de psy euh avec qui il se
forment, avec qui il débrief, avec qui
il raconte,
avec qui euh justement je crois que
c'est faisable sûrement
parce que si s'il y a pas ça, ça
favorise quoi les crimes de guerre ? Ça
favorise quoi les exactions ? Ça
favorise quoi ?
Bah ça fabrique des Ça fabrique des
genres de transgressions qui vont se
payer après dans l'autre sens,
c'està-dire forcément qui vont appeler à
la revanche. C'est inévitable.
Est-ce que vous dans vous savez c'est un
cercle après c'est un cercle c'est un
cercle sans fin
l'exaction de l'in va créer une exaction
dans le camp d'en face et ainsi de suite
pour se venger si on va enfin moi c'est
anecdotique parce que ça fait longtemps
que je manifeste plus mais j'avais
accompagné il y a j'étais à l'époque des
gilets jaunes là j'avais accompagné mon
fils là qui avait été une manife là mais
la présence physique moi qui avais fait
beaucoup de manifes quand j'étais jeune
mais j'avais été étonné de la présence
technique de la police presque à voyez
c'està dire un agacement continue il
fabrique il fabrique de l'agacement
donc ça ça c'est un choix ça c'est un
choix technique
c'est une doctrine
c'est une doctrine c'est une doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre ça c'estàdire il y a
il y a une façon d'encadrer
et de protéger et il y a une façon de
coller qui va faire problème
immédiatement
et moi-même physiquement je l'ai vécu
c'estàd on était emmerdé sans cess un
truc truc qui allait
Comment vous analysez les les
les blessures de guerre des gilets
jaunes ? C'est-à-dire les les
nuucléation, les blessures à la tête ?
Est-ce que est-ce que alors vous c'est
peut-être pas votre domaine est-ce que
vous analysez ça comme une technique de
contre-insurrection digne d'un pays du
tiers monde ? C'est-à-dire mutiler des
gens pour faire un exemple pour
dissuader les gens d'aller manifester
derrière ou c'est ça ou c'est simplement
des erreurs de tir parce que comme les
gars sont pas formés que bon ou qui joue
à Call of Duty toute la journée que le
headshot c'est 150 points c'est quoi ?
Moi je crois plutôt ça. C'est un50
points.
C'est un défaut de C'est un défaut de
commandement d'abord, un défaut de
formation.
Je crois plutôt ça. Je suis je suis pas
sûr qu'il
qu'il veuille vraiment comme ça
euh créer une peur telle que je crois
pas que ça puisse être une idéologie
possible. Ça en plus ça a jamais marché
dans l'histoire de enfin si dans des
pays complètement totalites. Et encore
on voit bien que même dans des pays très
totalitaire au bout d'un temps ça craque
ça craque néanmoins. Donc c'est pas donc
c'est peine perdu. Non moi je crois que
c'est des défauts il me semble des
défauts de formation des défauts de
déontologie
des défauts d'encadrement psychologique
sûrement. Alors parce que par exemple,
je parlais des militaires mais je sais
que dans la police c'est assez récent
qu'il y a des psychologues qui viennent
à composer. Ils étaient pas habitués.
Alors pour la gendarmerie, je saurais
pas dire.
On on ressaute du coqualan.
Ouais.
Euh les réseaux sociaux.
Oui.
Euh tout toutes ces plateformes où les
gamins peuvent interagir, le porno,
l'ultraviolence.
Maintenant, les gamins peuvent tomber
sur des des images de guerre sur bah
même les blessures qu'il y a eu sur les
sur les gilets jaunes. Le le gars, il
perd son œil parce qu'il se prend il se
prend un qui rentre sur la tête.
Qu'est-ce que ça crée ? Ça crée ça crée
des gamins qui sont totalement
imperméables. Ça crée des gamins, ça
peut varier. Est-ce que Est-ce que ça il
y a un mimétisme après ou ça change leur
grille de lecture ? Comment ça se passe
?
Non non, ça il faut être attend. Non, ça
vous avez raison. Ça a été souligné. euh
par des collègues plus spécialisés dans
des phénomènes d'addiction visuelle
comme ça. Ça ça crée quand même une
ça ça touche techniquement à ce qu'on
appelle nous les enfin la constitution
des zones fantasmatiques de l'existence.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a tous en nous des
scénettes fantasmatiques
euh qui peuvent être agressifs par côté
érotique par l'autre sexualisé. Bon et
qui qui nous qui nous accompagne
enfant puis un peu plus jeune à l'âge
adulte et qui forge notre entrée dans le
rapport à l'autre en général
avec l'humain en général avec les
amitiés avec la sexualité humaine
et donc l'influence alors le problème
est là c'est-à-dire que la répétition de
de scènes comme ça crues euh trop trop
répété trop répliqué
euh va faire un ungramme un peu un peu
alors ça veut pas dire que ça va
fabriquer des monstres, voyez,
systématiquement, c'est pas ça. Ça peut
fabriquer ça peut fabriquer à mon avis
aussi bien l'inverse, c'est-à-dire une
forme d'inhibition
à l'entrée de l'âge adulte, c'estàdire
ne pas savoir comment enfin rentrer en
contact avec l'autre puisque on a
engramé que que des motifs de violence
et de et de sadisme ou de sexualité
violente ou que sais-je, mais il est
vrai, il est vrai qu'il faut être
attentif. Ça ça a des conséquences
techniques sur la sur la
fantasmatisation,
ça c'est certain. C'est pour ça qu'on
conseille c'estàd priver l'enfant
maintenant des moyens modernes, il faut
pas rêver, c'est c'est il est trop tard.
C'est-à-dire les enfants mais les limité
techniquement qui a un accès en en en
heure en en terme de temps euh
particulier
qui reste un temps pour la lecture, qui
reste un temps pour autre chose pour le
jeu et et puis veiller alors là je sais
pas comment comment il on pourrait faire
mais veiller à ce que il y a pas accès
comme ça libre à aux sites les plus
cruels parce que effectivement ça
je dirais
Il faut pas se tromper complètement, ça
crée pas que de la monstruosité, ça peut
créer une forme une forme d'inhibition
généralisée. C'est-à-dire Ah oui,
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui à l'âge
adulte va dire "Moi, je sais même pas
comment faire avec l'autre parce que
j'ai peur de l'abîmer.
Je sais pas comment faire." Donc on a on
a parfois nous, moi j'en ai reçu en cur
des jeunes comme ça qui disaient "Mais
il faut que je réapprenne à me lier tout
simplement, à aimer." Je sais plus.
Vous parliez d'addiction visuelle. C'est
quoi une addiction visuelle ?
Oh bah c'est ça. On va maintenant on
appelle addiction.
Bon c'est un peu la mode. Vous savez
tout tout est devenu un peu
addicté maintenant. Enfin il y a des
addictions classiques, alcool, drogue et
maintenant qui sait beaucoup. Et puis
donc les addictions comme ça, c'est le
temps le temps visuellement passé et
puis il y a les maintenant même il parle
d'addiction sexuelle, c'est-à-dire les
vous savez c'est lié au groupe de
sexualité sous drogue
le chem sexe.
Oui. Qui crée alors moi j'ai appris ça,
j'en avais pas eu dans mon enf dans ma
clientèle si je peux dire régulièrement.
J'ai appris ça en me déplaçant auprès de
collègues
à Nice où j'avais été un colloque. Là,
il y a des jeunes collègues qui m'ont
raconté qui avaient affaire à des
demandes comme ça assez assez complexes.
C'est parce que c'est des jeunes qui en
groupe ne peuvent avoir de sexualité
qu'avec des drogues assez assez assez
embêtantes.
Quel type de drogue ? Euh bah c'est des
drogues de synthèse maintenant, c'est
même pas des drogues classiques.
Donc donc on rentre bon c'est des c'est
des univers auquels auquel les
effectivement les praticiens comme sont
attentifs
pour essayer d'avoir plutôt un propos de
prévention à l'égard des jeunes qui
soient eux-mêmes. C'est pas
bon voilà pour qu'il reste à peu près en
bon état tout de même.
comment votre votre corporation et votre
spécialisation
appréhendent l'intelligence artificielle
? Est-ce que euh vous vous sentez menacé
? Est-ce que euh vous pensez que
l'intelligence artificielle euh va créer
d'autres troubles ? Est-ce que
l'intelligence artificielle va pouvoir
remplacer les psychiatres ?
Bah non, bah ce qui est ce qui est
amusant c'est que
je crois je crois qu'il faut prendre la
mesure de
il y a quand même un séisme avec la
l'intelligence artificielle.
Moi que j'ai vécu, moi qui étais joueur
d'échec jusqu'à une époque, vous savez
quand le celui qui s'est fait battre là,
le le enfin le champion c'était qui ?
C'était SP qui le champion russe
justement enfin le grand champion russe
des échecs
un jour se fait battre par l'ordinateur.
On pensait que c'était impossible. Donc
ça date de je sais pas peut-être 10 ans
ou 15 ans. Et ce jour-là euh je me suis
dit "Ah oui là c'est un séisme."
C'est-à-dire on n jamais pu penser
qu'une machine quand même
intelligente entre guillemets euh
très entre guillemets
Oui. Oui. Pouvit pouvait quand même
battre parce que un champion d'échec
c'est pas rien. C'est c'est des gars qui
non seulement ont la mémoire des coups,
des parties, des mais qui sont capables
au moment même d'inventer une variante
pour désarsenner l'adversaire.
Bon et néanmoins,
il s'est enfin l'ordinateur l'a battu.
Je crois
vous êtes sûr que c'était c'était
Je crois que c'était Space. Oui, le je
crois pas que c'était Fisher. Crois que
c'était Spask.
C Je crois je crois je crois que euh la
variante en question était d à un bug.
Enfin, en tout cas, il y a un jour un
jour l'ordinateur règle son compte. Non,
alors on est rentré quand même. Bon, il
faut être honnête, on est rentré depuis
ce jour-là dans un autre monde et là
maintenant les gens se préoccupent
beaucoup comme il s'appelle de
l'ordinateur là qu'on peut questionner
euh
voilà qu'on peut questionner et qui peut
vous faire une thèse à votre place sur
Aristote si vous lui demandez.
Chat GBT. Oui,
voilà. péter.
Bon, moi je dirais c'est comme toujours,
faut rester.
Je crois que ça probablement ça va
autoriser des choses nouvelles d'aller
chercher des documents et de les
collecter à une vitesse inégalée qu'on
pourra qu'il est très difficile de faire
en bibliothèque et devoir des résumés
comme ça. Est-ce que ça peut remplacer
la complètement l'inventivité humaine ?
C'est moins sûr. On verra.
Mais mais faire obstacle à la
Je crois que
on pourra pas faire obstacle à
l'intelligence.
On pourra pas après que dans les
universités, dans les lieux de
formation,
on fasse on fasse attention à ce que à
ce que l'humain soit pas remplacé par la
machine, ça oui, je crois quand même un
professeur, c'est pas simplement
quelqu'un qui a des connaissances. C'est
quand même ce qu'on est en train de
faire, c'est-à-dire quelqu'un à qui on
parle,
qui est le professeur ici ? Aucun de
nous là.
Voyez ce que je veux dire ?
On pourrait dire une machine à sa place
pour Mais oui et non un médecin un
médecin
de votre médecin de famille pour
certains évidemment si vous avez qu'une
grippe on peut le remplacer par un
ordinateur qui vous dit c'est pas grave
prenez de l'aspirine. Mais en même temps
le médecin c'est pas que ça. Le médecin,
il va c'est celui qui c'est celui qui
connaît un peu votre vie, qui connaît
vos soucis, qui va vous demander
d'autres questions qui sont pas liés
directement à ce que vous venez
raconter, qui va garder la mémoire de
votre présence. Donc à mon sens, voilà,
il faut faire attention, c'est pas c'est
pas que technique l'intelligence humaine
et c'est une intelligence affective que
pour l'instant l'ordinateur pourra pas
produire
sur la surveillance de masse.
Oui.
Le fait qu'on soit pied avec nos
téléphones portables, le fait qu'on soit
pied avec notre historique de connexion,
le fait qu'on soit pied dans la rue avec
des caméras, le fait que maintenant avec
les JO en France, on va avoir la
capacité d'une surveillance
algorithmique très invasive. h
le fait qu'il y a des regroupements de
fichiers, des regroupements de data, euh
comment les ps perçoivent ça ? Ah
non, ça crée ce que la campan appelait
une paranoïa ordinaire.
Ça crée une paranoïa, c'est-à-dire on
vit on vit petit à petit et ça alors ça
bizarrement
on a eu des psychanalystes historiques
qui avaient comme ça une espèce
d'intuition hein. Et donc Lac a pu dire
en son époque que le on était pas à
l'abri d'une ce qu'il appelait une
paranoïa ordinaire. C'est-à-dire un mode
de rapport à la société qui serait
marqué par la projection, par ça ce que
vous dites, la surveillance, la
projectivité, un rapport à l'autre
paranoïque. Et il est il est vrai que ça
c'est c'est un des risques de nos
sociétés modernes
d'avoir le sentiment d'être et pied de
partout
et
et avec les effets que ça peut avoir de
défense à nouveau. C'est le problème de
créer des une insurrection un jour ou
l'autre comme on voit dans les films de
science-fiction.
Quelqu'un qui dit "Ah ben non, c'est
fini, je m'assurge."
Euh non non, il y a il y a il y a une ça
vous avez raison. Il y a l'anesthésie
affective d'un côté, le point de
mélancolie là, de mélancolisation et de
l'autre côté pour les raisons que vous
signalez cette espèce de de curiosité
par ano, bah même nous dans nos
professions, vous savez, on doit rendre,
je veux dire, moi pas tellement vraiment
mais bon, je me rends compte que même
les acteurs de santé, faut qu'ils
rendent compte sans arrêt de leur truc.
Il faut il faut le noter, il faut le
renoter, il faut le réexpliquer. On se
fait engueuler si la file active est pas
aussi bonne que celle de l'année
précédente, faut le justifier. Donc vous
êtes en permanence liqué
même enfin même comme médecin. Donc
enfin alors on s'habitue, on s'habitue.
Bon
et puis un jour et puis un jour les colf
on s'habitue et un jour on s'étonne que
les jeunes médecins ils veulent plus.
Ils disent "Bah non, nous non, on s'en
va, on fait autre chose." C'estàd le
problème des crises de vocation, c'est
ça aussi. C'est
donc
il faut peut-être retenir ce terme, moi
qui me paraît pas mal de paranoïa
ordinaire, c'estàdire enfin l'ordinaire
d'un monde
surveillé. Vous avez dû entendre parler
de ce concept de conspirationnisme.
Oui.
C'est quoi le conspirationnisme pour un
psy et comment il comment on fait pour
déconstruire, remettre le pied et
surtout ne pas accentuer ?
H
je vous écoute.
Alors ça c'est là on a déjà Oui, ça
c'est déjà difficile hein parce que le
conspirationnisme vous avez affaire
c'est un problème c'est que c'est pas de
la psychologie individuelle, elle est
déjà collective. C'està dire, il y a un
groupe, c'est un groupe de C'est un
groupe.
Est-ce qu'il faut lire Gustave Lebon euh
par exemple déjà ? Oui.
Pour le comprendre.
Oui, pour comprendre faut et puis il y a
la psychologie des foules là que Freud
avait raconté.
Et alors c'est plus délicat à manier
parce que justement on croit parler en
tête à tête et en fait vous parlez à un
groupe qui est solidaire par principe.
Alors néanmoins alors néanmoins est-ce
que ça peut se déconstruire ?
Enfin, en tout cas, il faut essayer, il
faut essayer comme on a vécu à l'époque
du Covid là où il se racontait, vous
savez bien, tout est n'importe quoi.
Faut essayer par
côté du gouvernement ou côté euh Non, le
gouvernement il à la limite il
suivait ce que disait le à tel ou tel
moment le
Ils étaient quand même un peu en roue
libre hein. Oui oui oui ils se sentou
parce que là là ils sont tous en train
de pleurer les antivax machin chose et
ains de suite mais quand on peut
comprendre aussi les antivax
bien sûr
il faut il faut d'abord essayer de
comprendre
bien sûr exactement
éviter de les juger
exactement
éviter de leur taper sur la tête éviter
de les insulter à longueur de journée
bien sûr bien sûr
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on insulte
un un un conspirationniste
toute la journée
les antiv ça risqu ils étaient pas tous
conspirationnistes par exemple moi j'ai
j'ai vu en proximité des des gens,
parfois même des soignants, des
éducateurs qui viennent de par exemple
ceux qui viennent de pays africain,
ils sont ils ont une espèce ils n'ont
pas le même rapport avec nous à à la
survaccination, à des tas de trucs.
C'est pas
quelques petits scandales en Afrique
aussi sur Oui. Oui. Non, je sais bien
mais je veux dire c'est des c'est des
c'est des c'est des individus qui ont
pas un rapport à la science comme ça, à
la rationalité comme la nôtre. Donc ça
leur plaît jusqu'à un certain point
d'être soumis à temps de Donc c'est pas
par conspiration qu'il se il se rétracte
et parfois il trouvent dans des discours
sociaux comme ça source à alimenter leur
mais non non moi j'ai vu même enfin des
gens très bien par exemple des
accompagnants de personnes âgées des
gens comme ça qui voulaient pas se
vacciner voyez parce que ils alors
évidemment alors le petit côté qu'on
pouvait leur dire c'est que il y avait
leur vie mais qui pouvaient mettre en
difficulté en péril la vie des gens
qu'ils étaient censés à Alors des fois
ça jouait un peu. On leur disait
faites-le au moins pour l'autre puisque
ça ça c'est ça
sans essayer de les convaincre sur le
cet argument il était véridique ou pas
le fait que
ça peut ça peut marcher moi j'ai
la vaccination ça faisait simplement
diminuer la charge virale au bout de 7
jours. H on contagieux.
Voilà.
D'accord.
Mais bon, on peut enfin c'est mais c'est
un exemple hein des autres. Mais après
les conspirationnistes, le problème
c'est que ça peut toucher des
bah il y a même des gens qu'on pense
vous savez bien il y a des gens qui ont
pensé que même les camps de la mort là
de la choa c'était c'était
c'est des inventions. Non mais c'est
pour dire que ça a pu être enfin
raconter
enfin comme si c'était une conspiration.
Nous on voit on on voit sur les réseaux
des conspirationnistes, des
anticonspirationnistes
et ils se pourrissent la gueule à
longueur de journée et ça ne fait que
les renforcer chacun de leur côté.
Ouais.
Plus plus ils se pourrissent plus ça
endurcit les autres en face et plus ils
répondent plus ça endurcit les autres en
face. Donc ils ont une dynamique à se
taper sur la gueule à longueur de
journée, à se faire passer pour des
débiles mentaux à longueur de journée.
Votre regard de psychiatre, est-ce que
c'est productif de faire comme ça ou
est-ce qu'il faudra peut-être avoir une
autre méthode, une autre approche ? Et
et
quand on voit ceux censés déradicaliser
les conspirationnistes,
ils ont pas de background,
ils ont aucune capacité à échanger avec
l'autre dans le respect,
il continuent à se cracher sur la
gueule. Euh
euh qu'est-ce que ça génère chez l'autre
de se faire cracher dessus à longueur de
journée ?
Oui, vous avez raison. Il faut jamais
avoir un discours comme ça de de
hauteur, de jugement euh et niy non plus
scientiste. C'est-à-dire penser que la
science sait tout de tout. C'est faux.
En mé en médecine on sait on sait pas
tout hein. En médecine. Alors en
psychiatrie encore moins.
Mais il faut il faut être humble,
c'est-à-dire par côté. C'estàd nous qui
avons des professions quand même
euh avec des connaissances, des savoirs,
des façons, des choses, mais il faut
rester humble. Il y a il y a plein de
zones où il faut reconnaître qu'on sait
pas. On sait pas tout simplement. On
sait pas. Donc la science
des trucs qu'on sait aussi mais quand
que la science ne sait pas.
Non mais il y a des il y a des choses
que la science sait quand même. Il y a
quand même un un
Non, il y a des choses que la science
sait. Non, bien sûr, il y a des il y a
des un certain nombre de choses où
si vous devez aller à l'hôpital et que
le chirurgien doit passer par telle
telle partie du corps pour réparer votre
main, théoriquement, c'est mieux qu'il
sache par où passer. C'est s'il savait
pas, c'est embêtant.
Des fois, il y a des chirurgiens qui
savent pas.
Donc, il y a il y a il y a des il y a
des niveaux, faut mieux être pratique et
dire on sait le faire. Il y a un
savoir-faire, comme on dit, il y a un
savoir-faire mais faut pas opposer
une forme d'obscurantisme une
rationalité universelle. Ça c'est ça
c'est pas une bonne idée. C'estàd si
vous avez face à des gens un peu
irrationnels
euh
ou bien qu' on des croyances un peu
enfin qui leur viennent ou de leur voilà
on sait pas ou même ou même comme on
voit chez nous des patients psychotiques
qui ont des vrais délires, on va pas les
critiquer, on va pas leur dire mais vous
êtes fous,
vous êtes stupide.
À quoi ça sert de dire ça ? Donc on
essaie de prendre en charge
des formes de paralogisme ou de
raisonnement logique qui sont les leurs
pour néanmoins leur dire "Bon d'accord,
mais comment on fait pour vivre ensemble
quand même ? Comment on va faire ?
Comment vous allez faire ? Donc c'est
voilà donc on est habitué au moins par
les grands voyez par les grandes
psychoses, par les grandes maladies de
l'âme à composer avec l'autre. On va pas
le critiquer, ça ça n'a aucun sens.
Et si on critique, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Attends, si vous critiquez le
patient, il vous envoie d'abord
enfin le contrat moral est rompu, enfin
l'alliance thérapeutique elle existe
plus et puis éventuellement il va vous
donner un mauvais coup parce que vous au
passage
ça vous est déjà arrivé ça ?
Ça m'est arrivé de me faire griffer.
Oui. Au sens propre.
Non non, ça arrive mais parce que des
fois les on est à la limite
effectivement de savoir comment tenir
quelque chose qui est trop trop
efflorescent.
Quel regard quel Quel regard vous portez
sur les camisoles de force, les
électrochocs et tout ce qui va avec ? Oh
non, je dirais il y a il faut avoir deux
deux niveaux de regard si vous voulez.
Il euh
d'une euh
il y a des confins en psychiatrie.
Euh ça toujours été qui moi je moi qui a
longtemps été dans les hôpitaux, il y a
il y a des pas en nombre mais il y a il
y a un certain nombre de difficultés
techniques pratiques qui peuvent
autoriser
à prendre telle mesure qui peut paraître
un peu inhumaine mais si on ne le fait
pas c'est la mort assurée pour le
patient lui-même. C'estàdire en fait ils
en meurent. ou il tue, il tue, il meurt.
Donc donc il y a il y a une zone où
justement la science a pas été au-delà
de ces possibilité, on est obligé de
contenir. Ça peut arriver. Après ce qui
est très grave, c'est la généralisation
de ces pratiques. Ça c'est autre chose.
Moi, quand j'étais dans dans les grands
hôpitaux, il y avait telle ou telle
cellule entre guillemets fermées, telle
ou telle chambre capitonnée. On était
appelé en renfort la nuit pour faire des
injections à tel patient un peu
difficile, tel autre. Euh mais c'était
pas tout l'hôpital qui était comme une
prison ou des choses. Et donc le
problème c'est qu'on a induit toujours
pareil par faute de moyen humain.
C'est de l'abattage et c'est une
par faute de convivialité par faute de
parce que il y avait on avait une très
belle tradition de psychothérapie
institutionnelle en France quand même
c'est-à-dire vivre avec les patients,
pas simplement les surveiller.
Et maintenant, vous rentrez dans des
certains hôpitaux effectivement avec des
abus et et de médicaments pour être
tranquille, faut les faire dormir et de
choses un peu un peu agressives parce
que parce qu'il y a pas le personnel en
rapport et donc ils ont peur.
Vous avez fréquenté un peu les prisons ?
Non non non. Alors là, ça doit ça doit
être encore, je pense, pour les
collègues qui travaillaient dans les
services de santé des prisons, ça
existe. Ça doit être pareil, c'est
encore plus difficile.
Alors surtout que par faute de moyens,
des fois on met des patients
psychotiques des vrais en prison. Donc
les autres patients enfin les autres
prisonniers on ont peur déjà et les
matons aussi c'est encore pire. Les
gardiens de prison.
Oui. Donc les gardiens de prison ont
peur à justement à tort ou à raison. les
autres compagnons des prisonniers en
peur et les les patients sont pas
traités comme des patients, c'est des
prisonniers.
Non, je crois que ça c'est c'est une
tristesse. C'est pareil ça. On manque de
dialogue, de discours, de position, de
alors qu'on a vécu pourtant toute cette
richesse qu'on l'a eu en France. Voyez,
on a eu très belle époque de la de la
dite psychothérapie institutionnelle
qu'une institution soit un lieu de vie,
même avec la folie.
s'agissait pas de les condamner ou de
les ou de les juger. La question était
qui ça puisse un minimum vivre en
collectivité.
Mais alors, on a on a régressé. Alors
voilà, donc il faut différencier des des
mesures techniques qu'on doit prendre à
l'occasion pour ça même les
électrochocs, ça se fait dans la dans la
psychose maniacodépressive, voyez, dans
des choses.
De mon expérience, si vous ne le faites
pas, c'est le problème, c'est que ça
peut être fatal. C'est c'est un choix
c'est un choix du praticien ça d'aller
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il faille
le généraliser. Ça c'est un autre
problème. On on voit passer euh quelques
études sur la prise de microse de
champignon hallucinogène.
Oui, c'est vrai. Euh on voit passer des
trucs des gars qui font laayawaska
genre des tripes hallucinatoires.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Non, pas grand-chose. Moi, je suis comme
vous. C'est des fois je suis étonné des
études qui se font ailleurs que chez
nous. des ça d'ouvrir d'ailleurs
en particulier il y a certains certains
produits qui servent pour les douleurs
chroniques c'estàd
pas les champignons forcément mais des
produits qui en principe seront
interdits en France.
Vous parlez des canabignoles ?
Voilà. Oui, par exemple le cannabis.
Mais ça en France, on a on est frileux
sur les expériences comme ça. Souvent ça
vient de d'autres d'autres pays
avoisinant
en Europe qui nous dit et donc on
s'aperçoit qu'il il y a des gammes de
souffrances souvent physiques qui
trouvent à se compenser.
Donc moi je reste comme ça à observer, à
me demander.
Mais là le
souvent l'État français est assez ils
savent pas trop comment prendre des
choses entre l'autorisation par
l'autorisation. Alors ça passe ça passe
par des biais autres souvent parce que
maintenant on peut recevoir par la poste
qu'on veut.
Pourquoi vous faites livrer quelque
chose ?
Non moi non mais moi j'ai jamais été
tellement produit comme ça mais je n'ai
pas vraiment le j'ai pas tellement non
plus de clientèle de patients comme ça.
Donc
revenons revenons à à un autre sujet. Ça
vous vous avez déjà récupéré des enfants
syriens radicalisés ? euh
endoctriné par Al-Qaïda, des parents
doctrinés ou des choses comme ça.
Non, sur le sur le nombre. Non, non,
non,
non. On a eu des enfants qui nous
venaient des des pays arabes bien
entendu
et euh
j'en ai non assez non c'est vrai pendant
que vous me posez la question aurait pu
penser que sur le nombre à l'occasion il
y avait des jeunes qui se radicalisaient
ou des
à ma connaissance et on en a pas entendu
parler non plus après donc à l'évidence
on n pas on n'est pas tombé sur des cas
comme ça
les gamins que vous récupérez soit ils
ont vécu dans la rue soit ils Ils ont
vécu des des migrations absolument
horribles. Ils ont vécu de la guerre.
Ils ont vécu quoi
? Non, les gamins, bah les gamins qu'on
récupère, ils viennent de tous les pays
troublés, vous connaissez. C'est-à-dire
à l'époque, il y avait les il venait du
Caucas pour enfin il y avait les vous
savez les tout ce qui se passait en
Russie au confin de la Russie là la
Tchini des pays comme ça.
Euh on avait déjà beaucoup beaucoup
d'enfants qui venaient d'Afrique
sub-saharienne en fonction des tensions
ou des famines ou des ou des guerres ou
des qui se passaient dans leur pays. Il
y avait des enfants qui venaient des des
pays où il y a des problèmes religieux
interreligieux
au Sri Lanka, au Bangladesh, au sacra
coup de bâchette ou
entre entre voisins. Voilà, il y a ça.
Alors ça, on Donc si on fait le tour et
Ronda Rwanda vous avez eu
à l'époque alors non, le Rwanda on l'a
pas eu, c'était déjà c'était il y a trop
loin.
Et puis et vous avez aussi alors c'est
une une autre gamme de questions mais
qu'on qu'on peut il faut quand même la
nommer, c'est les c'est les fillettes
qui fuient les par exemple les excisions
rituelles ou les mariages forcés.
Donc là, c'est les mères, c'est les
mamans qui les qui les sortent seul du
pays avec leurs filles, avec leur
petites filles. Donc on a on a toute
toute cette gamme de de jeunes. Alors,
il faut dire alors faut faire attention,
ils sont pas à la rue quand ils arrivent
hein la plupart quand en principe quand
les enfants arrivent en France.
en principe
en principe hein mais quand même enfin
nous nous ceux qu'on reçoit ils sont
dans les vous savez dans les ce qu'on
appelle les cadas les centres d'accueil
des demandeurs d'asile hein les cadas
c'est des c'est des c'est des centres
qui sont gérés par les les grandes
associations que vous connaissez là
France Terre d'asile
qui est la plus grosse mais il y a il y
a aussi Koalia qui est une association
issue de la résistance française pendant
la guerre ou bien des trucs trucs comme
le CASP, centre d'action sociale
protestant, enfin des gens qui ont
délégation
à recevoir les familles et les et les
enfants de l'exil. Donc ils sont ils
sont quand même logés là. Ils sont
logés, ils sont protégés et ils font
leur demande ils font leur demande
d'asile officiellement à la République
française. Et alors ce qui est ce qui
est quand même alors pour dire un truc
bien sur la France,
on dit que des trucs bien sur la France.
Oui, oui, pour dire un truc bien auquel
je tiens à dire, c'est que néanmoins
l'enfant qui arrive très vite, il va
être scolarisé. C'estàd que les écoles
françaises
les reçoivent si dédié quasiment pas.
L'enfant arrive à Roissi,
il se peut que 3 semaines après, un mois
plus tard, il rentre à l'école qu'il ait
des papiers ou pas.
C'est quand même ça la France
ça. Ça c'est quand même Non mais c'est
il faut il faut d'ailleurs remercier
l'éducation quand même. Enfin les
enseignants, les directeurs d'école, les
direct c'est énorme. C'estàdire il les
laissent pas hors école et quand
l'enfant arrive à l'école et voyez pour
un enfant qui comme ça qui vient de si
loin qui a vécu des trucs, il sait pas
si son père est vivant, s'il est ceci.
C'est énorme. Il va à l'école, il
découvre que il peut y être accueilli,
qu'il y a des adultes qui l'accueillent,
qu'il y a des enfants des autres et il
est en collectivité. Et donc le même
enfant en principe en principe parce que
c'est pareil, il peut être suivi de
manière sanitaire quand même en
principe, je dis bien c'est toutes les
unités ont pas fait ce qu'on a fait
nous. dégager un un temps spécial pour
se faire mais
un certain nombre l'effort quand même de
pouvoir accueillir. Donc l'enfant peut
être donc éduqué en France et et soigné
entre guillemets, accompagné.
Euh non, il
sort de l'école, qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand il sort de l'école ? quand il
sort, on voulait dire euh
quand il quand il sort à à la fin des
cours, il
Ah bah à la fin des cours, bah soit soit
dans le meilleur des cas, il il revient
au cada, là où ses parents sont
hébergés, soit dans le pire des cas dans
les dans les familles non reconnues par
l'État français ou qui ne sont pas le gé
Bah malheureusement on sait on sait même
pas, ils traînent ils traînaillent quoi.
Vous pouvez avoir des enfants qui sont à
l'école et puis qui éventuellement le
soir il ils vont être on sait pas où.
Oui,
les enfants entre eux quand il y a un
petit bout qui vient de l'autre bout
l'autre bout du monde, est-ce que il
communique avec les autres pour
expliquer ce qui lui arrive ? Est-ce que
les autres enfants lui posent des
questions ? Est-ce qu'il y a un
phénomène de transfert ? Est-ce qu'il y
a des choses qui se passent entre les
Alors, je crois que oui, ça c'est
intéressant
votre question parce que je me suis posé
la même question même pour nous de
manière technique. Comment comment on
faisait ? Comment on faisait ? Est-ce
est-ce qu'il faut faire est-ce qu'il
faut faireablement le le récit hein le
récit des des choses des traumas ?
Est-ce que il est nécessaire d'en passer
par le long récit des parfois des
traumas les plus difficiles
ou bien euh
alors je dirais qu' bah c'est comme tout
à l'heure moi je réponds moi je réponds
des deux manières en même temps.
C'est-à-dire l'enfant,
vous avez des enfants par exemple, il va
vous il va raconter alors souvent c'est
par le dessin.
Il va raconter chaque semaine le même
dessin de sa grand-mère avec un un
pistolet sur la te parce que il l'a vu
tuer sous ses yeux.
Par quelle force,
hein ?
Par quelle quelle armée ?
Euh bah là c'était
là c'était dans mon souvenir c'est c'est
c'était plus un pays proche de la Russie
là mais bon.
Et donc ça, cet enfant-là,
il a pas de choix. Il faut qu'il
raconte, qu'il raconte, qui raconte, qui
raconte et il faut attendre. Il raconte.
Bon, donc c'est une une réponse pour
l'enfant dont on comprend qu' il est
monoidéique. Il inlassablement, il va
raconter
ou que sa mère avait été violée ou qu'il
y a eu ceci. OK. Bon, obligé de
l'écouter bien entendu. Il y a pas
Alors, est-ce qu'il va raconter ça aux
autres enfants de l'école ? moins sûr,
mais il va se
voyez se terrer un peu sur lui-même le
le temps que
Mais alors ça c'est une des dimensions.
L'autre dimension que on a pris pour
option dans le service là justement avec
tous ces enfants qui venaient du bout du
monde avec des traumas variés, c'est de
c'est de j'ai pris la formule de déposer
on fait qu'ils puissent déposer
transitoirement leur mémoire
individuelle.
la leure ils écrivent
il la non il la dépose au s non enf
c'est pas le bon terme il la laisse de
côté transitoirement
c'estàdire on ne parle ni de leur
mémoire ni de leur famille mais ils
viennent en groupe
se saisir d'une mémoire qui est celle
par exemple de la voyez de la mythologie
he la mémoire de la mythologie qui va
raconter
he vous savez que la mythologie ça
raconte ça raconte quand même des crimes
et des atrocités aussi à sa façon, hein,
c'est-à-dire l'enfant. Donc, les
enfants, on a choisi qui se séparent
transitoirement de leur mémoire propre.
Et quand ils sont avec nous dans un
groupe comme ça,
on étudie, si je peux dire, une mémoire
universel qui va quand même parler de
qui va quand même parler de la
destructivité,
mais pas que. Souvent dans un mythe,
vous avez l'héros et à vous avez enfin
réuni la guerre et la et l'amour.
Et donc on a voyez, on a les deux
aspects techniques, c'est-à-dire
l'enfant qui ne peut pas faire autrement
que raconter on l'écoute ou il dessine.
Les autres enfants en groupe ont fait en
sorte que transitoirement ils se ils se
délaissent de de ce trauma et se trouve
réunis en s'apercevant que les que toute
l'histoire enfin de l'humanité est faite
est faite de grands de grands séismes.
effectivement ce que raconte très bien
la mythologie grecque en l'occurrence
mais d'autres aussi bien
voilà mais ça voyez c'est un aspect
technique que j'aime bien c'estàd ça ça
nous oblige à être sur deux bords
sans sans valoriser le tout traumatique
d'un côté obligatoirement le récit
traumatique mais on l'accueille s'il le
faut et à l'autre bout
d'être d'être dans un patou patou du
trauma en en étant dans des questions
universelles que l'enfant enfant
évidemment enfin comprend très petit
déjà enfin les comptes les légendes et
les limites il s'en saisit très petit
les écoles le corps enseignant
il ils reçoivent une formation comment
ils gèrent le truc quand on
je vous laisse répondre je vois d'autres
lignés de la tête pour ceux qui
si moi je trouve qu'il se ils se
débrouillent pas mal hein c'est-à-dire
il y a ils ont fait l'effort des fois de
faire des comment ils appellent ça je
sais plus le nom que ça mais c'est des
classes dédiées pour des enfants qui
évidemment parlent encore très mal le
français en arrivant
Donc ils font un effort technique pour
le pour les accueillir le temps que
l'enfant Alors l'enfant petit apprend
assez vite le français hein. On est
étonné en quelques mois il arrive il
arrive tout à fait à comprendre puis à
lire. Mais non, ils font ils font des
après les écoles se plaignent comme nous
du c'est pareil, vous savez c'est tout
bête hein, c'est les manques de moyens,
les manques d'aide, les manques de
réunion à côté, les manques de
ça va pas s'arranger
mais ça pourrait être facile que ça
alors en plus c'est bébê parce que les
enseignants sont moi il se fait que par
ma fonction
j'assiste, je suis au conseil
scientifique des enseignants de
maternel,
je suis le seul psy enfin psychanalyste
membre du conseil scientifiquement. Et
donc je vais je vais une fois l'an au
congrès des enseignants de maternel qui
est génial parce que parce que les
maternels ça reste quand même un univers
du enf ça reste joyeux, c'est
intéressant, c'est amusant
et on voit on voit comment on voit
comment facilement les enseignants quand
ils sont accompagnés qu'ils ont le temps
de discuter entre eux, qu'ils ont le
temps de réfléchir, ils produisent des
ils produisent des choses formidables.
Ce que sont les maternels à la française
d'ailleurs, vous savez que ça nous est
envié par tous les pays du monde.
Donc je dirais c'est voilà, il faut il
faut garder c'est pour ça je vous disais
un peu d'espoir à l'occasion. Combien de
temps un enfant vous le suivez ou c'est
un
Ah bah alors le problème il il va être
ça va vraiment être suivant l'accueil de
la République là c'est-à-dire l'enfant
bon pour pour que vous savez c'est lent
l'administration française alors déjà il
va y avoir une une bonne année avant
d'avoir la réponse savoir si si l'État
le reconnaît ou pas comme réfugié donc
tout ce temps-là on va le suivre puisque
ensuite alors ensuite une fois alors
s'il est déclaré réfugié
Ce qui est bien dans le meilleur des
cas, on
lui dit que du coup il est plus voilà,
il est comme tous les autres enfants
maintenant, on lui explique, il a le
droit à tout
mais l'État français
très vite les envoie en dehors de
l'Île-de-France. Il y a une répartition
géographique
qui après tout après tout pour ce qu'on
en sait par les familles qui nous disent
après où ils vont souvent dans des
villes où ils trouvent du travail, les
parents trouvent du travail, bon ils
peuvent se loger correctement. Bon donc
ils sont répartis très vite donc ils
nous disent au revoir, on les quitte
ceuxl. Bon je dirais que c'est c'est pas
si mal. Et puis il y a ceux il y a ceux
qui sont déboutés. Et lorsqu débout du
droit d'asile, l'État enfin refuse.
Alors là, il rentre il rentrent dans un
trou noir ceux-là. C'est-à-dire les
cadas au bout d'un temps n'ont plus le
droit de les garder. Ils les gardent un
peu parce que ils savent théoriquement
l'État peut pas les protéger au-delà.
Personne va les ramener à l'avion pour
qu'il rentre au pays. Ça existe ou c'est
très rare non plus. Donc il rentrent
dans un trou noir. C'est-à-dire ils ils
existent pas civilement. sait puis ce
qui deviennent. Donc certains on les
suit encore mais là c'est douloureux
hein. C'est douloureux de les voir pour
les équipes ceuxlà parce que soit soit
soit ils appellent SOS toutes les nuits
là pour savoir où loger. Des fois ils
sont à la rue, des fois ils sont à
droite, des fois ils sont à gauche. Dans
le meilleur des cas, ils trouvent un peu
de soutien communautaire quand ils
savent à quoi se rattacher.
Et donc on a on a après voyez une
bifurcation entre ceux qui sont honorés
du droit d'asile, bon qui vont continuer
leur route et ceux qui sont non
reconnus. Et là on rentre, on rentre
complètement dans l'invisibilité.
Ils deviennent ils deviennent
invisibles. Ils deviennent invisibles.
Alors des fois l'école les garde quand
même. Effectivement euh il reste
scolarisé, on il garde un lien avec une
structure sanitaire mais bon c'est pas
question
question internet. Oui.
Peut-il nous expliquer concrètement la
différence entre la psychanalyse
freudienne et lacienne ?
Ah alors non, Lacan n'aimerait pas parce
que lui se dit frodien.
Non, c'est lié mais au-delà de la
blague, c'est lié au fait qu'il y a il y
a depuis Freud
plusieurs traditions différentes de la
haute tradition de la psychanalyse.
Il y a
la tradition, une très belle tradition
qu'on appelle encore l'école anglaise de
psychanalyse.
C'est les noms que vous connaissez
Flawiou Nicot, Mélanie Klin
qui ont qui ont travaillé pendant la
guerre en Angleterre, la Seconde Guerre
qu'on continue à suivre les suivre les
et donc c'est une très belle tradition
qui a essé aux États-Unis par côté.
Donc ça c'est la tradition dit d dit
anglaise hein. En France en France on a
eu euh transitoirement
transitoirement ce Lacan là qui s'est
fait s'est fait reconnaître par ses
talents, son enseignement et qui et qui
je dirais n'a n'a jamais
ne s'est jamais a jamais dit qu'il
faisait table race de freud rien hein.
il a veillé à à complémenter comme dans
chaque science humaine, je dirais ce que
Freud avait laissé en en germe. Donc il
y a des zones où la campan a apporté un
certain nombre de singularités propre à
la psychanalyse française. Mais
maintenant qu'il a disparu, on en
revient après une science, même la
psychanalyse, faut qu'elle se
complémente, faut qu'elle invente, faut
qu'elle reste Moi, je suis très sensible
aux traditions qui nous viennent de
pays. Là, je parlais du Brésil, ils sont
excellents nos collègues brésiliens.
Au Canada, ils sont pas mal non plus. Au
Canada, il y a une tradition. Même aux
États-Unis, on critiqué les États-Unis
par leur pharmacopé, mais il y a une
tradition psychopathologique qui est
très bonne. En Italie, il y a des
psychanalystes qui écrivent des choses
excellentes. On est dans une période un
peu entre nous un peu plus d'ouverture
au donc Lacan bien entendu, mais pas que
Lacan non plus. Et puis la maintenant ça
commence à sa façon à dater aussi à
chaque génération.
Alors après est-ce est-ce qu'il faut des
grands maîtres comme ça ? Ça c'est un
autre problème parce que c'est pas
évident. Il y a pas toujours eu un un
grand seigneur ou une on a eu la chance
d'avoir Dolton nous aussi. Enfin, il y
avait d'autres les grandes analystes
féminines.
Bon, enfin même les Chinois sont mis à
la psychanalyse, on n'est pas à l'abri
qui nous invent, on sait pas.
Ça fait longtemps qu'ils sont mis à la
psychianalise.
Oui, mais comme ils vont vite et qu'ils
sont nombreux.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du de ce
nouveau concept de psychiatriser
l'ennemi ou de psychiatriser
l'adversaire politique ou de
psychiatriser l'adversaire tout court ?
Il est fou, c'est un psychopathe, il est
machin, il est comme si. C'est c'est une
façon de quoi ? C'est c'est de priver
l'autre d'une intégrité. C'est c'est de
ne pas écouter l'autre. C'est de se
rassurer pour éviter une remise en
question, une conduite introspective par
rapport à ce qu'on pourrait avoir ou ce
que l'autre nous renvoie. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ?
Moi, je suis d'accord avec vous. Je
crois que ça sert à rien. Je crois que
ça sert à rien de dire de parce que moi
j'entends ça aussi comme vous de dire
qu'un un dirigeant et ceci ou cela à
l'époque à l'époque on avait dit
d'Hitler qu'il était ceci ou cela. Ça
presque aucune importance. Le problème
est pas là. problème est que est que ce
type quand même un peu
Oui, mais je veux dire à la limite à la
limite il
était archi drogy, il était
Oui. Oui. Mais ça nous apporte pas
grand-chose. Ce qui est ce qui est ce
qui est grave et le plus et le plus qui
reste le plus énigmatique, c'est comment
un type arrive autour de sa propre
personne à faire un usage enfin
populaire. C'est ça c'est ça le problème
clinique pour moi. C'est comment un
peuple éventuellement pas tout le peuple
enfin une partie du peuple peut être
asservi à une folie qu'elle soit
vraiment folle ou pas tout à fait folle.
C'est ça. C'est ça que lui-même que le
gars soit un peu ceci ou cela à la
limite ça presque aucune importance pour
moi. Donc je dirais psychiatriser des
et puis à l'inverse moi j'aime pas qu'on
qu'on donne de noms enfin des noms de
folie. C'est ça déqualifie la folie à
l'inverse. Ce qui est bizarre
humainement.
C'est quoi la folie ?
La folie depuis la nuit des temps et
chez les Grecs, c'était respecté. Chez
les il y a une place pour les pour les
folies. Il y a il y a du il y a de la
folie. Il y a des fous
parce que les fili laissent passer et
les fous et les fous sont pas ceux.
On parlait on parlait tout à l'heure,
mais c'est par blague un peu mais en
même temps ça fait réfléchir. On parlait
tout à l'heure du fait qu'on soit tous
envahis par les ondes maintenant
surveiller de partoutin. Mais nos
patients psychotiques, ils nous le
disaient il y a 20 ans ça. Il disait
"Mais moi je suis je vais à la
boulangerie, on me surveille, je vais
donc on les prenait pour des fous bien
entendu.
Une filet qui sait qu' a raison.
Non, c'est pour dire que le fou, le vrai
fou, celui qui a l'hôpital
psychiatrique,
il vit sans abri un réel. Il raconte son
rapport heurté au réel du monde
qui qui à la limite, dans le meilleur
des cas, doit nous enseigner.
C'est-à-dire, c'est c'est intéressant de
se dire "Mais qu'est-ce qu'il dit ? De
quoi il parle ?" Et on s'aperçoit que
souvent les thématiques des fous, c'est
de nous prévenir que notre rapport au
réel et le nôtre, il est il est tout à
fait petit, segmenté. On n' pas on n'
pas idée de ce qu'est le monde et d'ù et
d'où quand on l'a de force l'angoisse
dans laquelle et la dépression dans
laquelle ça nous met quand on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement les réels sont bien
aussi catastrophiques que ça. Donc donc
je dirais c'est pour ça que j'aime pas
qu'on psychiatrise parce que c'est à
l'inverse maltraiter les folies
et sur les dictateurs ça nous apprend
souvent rien. Faut être honnête. Vous
vous avez suivi euh euh la prison d'Abou
Ghraï, vous avez suivi les tortures de
Guantanamo, vous avez les tortures par
la musique,
les waterboarding, ça je me rappelle.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit d'une société quand
elle torture ? Quand elle torture avec
de la musique, h
quand elle fait des simulacres
d'exécution,
quand elle
qu'est-ce que ça dit ? Et vous en tant
que psychiatre
voir la passivité intellectuelle de nos
élites face à ça, de ne pas prendre des
position ferme sur bah vous torturez ses
noms
et c'est non jusqu'au bout. C'est-à-dire
les accords commerciaux ça saute,
votre pouvoir de décision ça saute
jusqu'à tant que vous redeveniez
civilisé.
Est-ce qu'il faut alors je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable. Est-ce qu'il faut
être plus bourreau que le bourreau ?
C'est-à-dire, est-ce qu'il faut aller
jusqu'à la folie de torturer les gens ou
il faut prendre du recul ?
Non, non, mais ça vous avez, moi je suis
d'accord avec vous. Non non, il faut
prendre il faut je dirais qu'il faut
aller peut-être à la à la limite. C'est
un peu c'est un peu ça, je l'étudie avec
les enfants l'histoire du minotaur là,
vous savez propos des mythes.
C'est-à-dire quand le héros grec
s'avance
dans l'entre là où il y a le minotaur
dans le labyrinthe. Oui. Et là il sait
il sait que a priori il va pas en
ressortir. Il demande à sa troupe de
rester derrière parce que principe
et alors c'est ça qui est troublant et
ça que les enfants il il découvrent.
C'est à pleurer. C'estàdire il il est
dit dans le mythe que tout d'un coup il
il voit les yeux du minotaure
et dans les yeux du minotaure il y a un
moment de stupeur du héros grec puisque
il voit l'enfant il voit les yeux
d'enfant que le minotor était.
que le minotur ce n'était qu'un enfant
monstrueux qui avait été mis au rebut,
qui était devenu un monstre.
Et donc il est a quelque chose,
c'est-à-dire il voit l'humanité du
monstre.
Est-ce qu'il crée un moment de
C'est ça qui manque à nos sociétés
maintenant.
Et oui, ça c'està-dire lui il reconnaît
avant la lutte à mort, il reconnaît que
le problème est que l'autre est pas est
pas inhumain uniquement.
Et alors après ce qui alors qu'après il
y a un passage qui est assez particulier
où pour battre le monstre, il est obligé
de de se battre,
il mime ses gestes sur ceux du monstre.
Il devient monstre.
Alors il y a un enfant. Alors justement
moi je lisais ça et puis donc le groupe
là de lecture là que je vous dis et puis
j'ai un enfant assez petit hein, il
avait peut-être 10 ans et il me dit "Ah
bah donc quand on rentre dans le
labyrinthe, on devient un monstre."
J'ai dit mais pourquoi tu dis ça ? Elle
me dit si c'est écrit. Il avait raison.
On on relit le passage à cause de ce
passage où tout d'un coup la lutte à
mort fait que il est à la limite à la
limite. Donc il faut mieux il faut mieux
se dire qu'effectivement comment sait-on
qu'on est à quelle limite on va à quelle
limite on est à quelle limite mais dans
le même passage il y a a la
reconnaissance de l'humain dans
l'inhuma. C'està-dire c'est c'est les
deux.
Non, c'est très beau hein ce problème.
Mais après quand c'est des décisions, le
problème là, c'est ce que vous évoquez,
c'est des décisions d'État. C'est autre
chose là. C'est-à-dire c'est l'État qui
accepte la monstruosité parce que les
prisons avec les tortures.
L'État c'est qui ?
Oui. Non mais je veux dire c'est c'est
un niveau là de de responsabilité
de de la transmission à tout un peuple.
C'est énorme. C'est énorme.
Créer ses propres démons ensuite.
Exactement. C'est-à-dire si à tout un
peuple vous dites il est légitime euh
bah comme on a eu nous euh moi je me
rappelle très bien même dans ma famille
euh on discutait l'histoire de la guerre
d'Algérie. Euh c'est-à-dire euh Quid,
c'est légitime ou c'était ?
Non non, là vous avez raison, on touche
à des à des questions de je dirais bah
là c'est presque il faudrait prendre le
terme, c'est même pas la déontologie,
c'est l'éthique. C'est l'éthique. Est-ce
qu'il y a un point d'éthique dans une
société ou pas ? Pour les classiques,
oui.
Est-ce que l'éthique Est-ce que
l'éthique va pas sombrer avec ce qui
nous attend ?
Bah c'est c'est un risque
à force de s'anesthésier.
C'est un risque. À force de
s'anesthésier, on perd le sens du
tragique et donc de l'éthique. Vous avez
raison bien sûr, c'est le risque. C'est
le risque. C'est le risque. C'est pour
c'est pour ça qu'il faut enfin il faut
c'est pour ça que prendre appui sur les
sur les sur les sujets les qui sont
martyres de ça. C'estàd il y avait eu
les psychotiques, les fous et qui
étaient pas si bien traité. Là
maintenant c'est les c'est les questions
de l'exil et d'autres.
Alors sur sur l'exil sur Je vais prendre
une autre question.
Allez-y.
Alors,
j'en profite pour prendre un peu d'eau.
Je vous en prie. Alors, laquelle que tu
veux que je pose ? Celle-ci. En vivant
tout ça, en étant sur le terrain,
comment vous vous vivez le discours sur
la gestion des flux migratoires ?
Comment voyez-vous l'avenir ? Alors,
vous êtes pas spécialiste des flux
migratoires, ni géographes, ni quoi que
ce soit.
Donc vous êtes pas obligé de répondre à
la question.
Si si si, je vais je vais essayer. Bah
d'abord moi j'utilise jamais les mots
comme flux migratoire. On dit même pas
déshumanise. C'est ça.
Dans mon service, on dit même pas les
migrants. Nous, on dit les sujets de
l'exil, on a fait exprès. Ça reste des
sujets.
Même migrant, même le terme migrant, on
l'utilise pas. C'est pas qu'il migre
pas, mais migrant. Bon, on appelle ça
les sujets et les petits sujets de
l'exil quand c'est les enfants.
Je peux vous couper. Oui.
Travestir la langue française comme ça,
dire les migrants, les les flux.
Les flux, ou
c'est une façon de se protéger des
politiques.
Non non non, c'est une tradition. On l'a
eu vous savez c'est le on l'a eu sous le
trisème reichàd
ça l'atteinte de la langue ça été
documenté hein.
On appelait ça dit amt fr en allemand
c'est-à-dire le langage administratif il
parlait en terme de flux. Bah déjà avec
les camions, les trucs, c'était des flux
pour les donc on sait déjà ça. Les gens
manquent de mémoire.
C'est une nouvelle novel langue.
Oui. Oui. Ça a été racontter comment
atteindre à la langue ça permet de faire
passer les pires saloperies. Donc un
flux migratoire ça n'a presque aucun
sens comme propos. On est dans des je
vais dire bon bref donc
il y a pas de bref.
Non il y a pas de bref. Non. Il faudrait
il faudrait dire à ces gens qui parlent
comme ça qui
au moins qui se document sur des faits
d'histoire qu'on déjà raconté ça.
Toucher à toucher au mots toucher aux
choses. touché effectivement.
Après après je moi je pense je suis pas
le seul que d'une la question à cause
des crises dans le monde entier, des
crises climatiques, des crises de
sécheresse, des crises de on a on aura
dans les années qui viennent forcément
une pression des questions de migration,
ça fait pas de doute.
Je crois qu'on peut pas on peut pas
comme on le fait cyniquement donner au
pays du Maghreb ou au Turcs le soin de
faire que on voit comment il traite ça,
il militarise les la chose.
Oui. Donc ça, on prépare des bon
moi alors moi là-dessus parce que je me
permets d'en parler parceil se fait que
pour des raisons à la fois de famille et
certains patients patientes que je suis
qui sont très au courant de ces
questions, je pense qu'on devrait
prendre un peu exemple de la façon dont
des pays qui sont voisins des nôtres
comme l'Allemagne ont quand même ils ont
répondu autrement sans faire de de
grands discours sur les flux.
En considérant que les que nos pays de
toute manière de manière toute bête,
presque utilitaire ont besoin ont besoin
de migrants, ont besoin de migration et
donc il faut les accueillir, les former,
les intégis
étonné, j'avais vu bah sur Artaré
raconter ça que même en Italie là qui
pourtant est pas tendre, il y avait il y
avait des entrepreneurs italiens
maintenant qui se plaignaient que leur
que leur industrie pouvait pas
fonctionner parce que ils avaient pas
ils avaient plus de monde, c'est tout.
C'est tout bête. Ils avaient personne à
qui à qui demander à faire le boulot.
Donc je dirais bon bref, il faut il faut
raison garder d'une ça va pas cesser.
Deux,
il y a sûrement des besoins des besoins
humains nouveaux qu'il faut qu'il faut
qualifier
et trois et trois le à mon sens pour
l'instant le nombre,
je veux dire le les les le truc du grand
remplacement là en nombre, c'est rien du
tout hein.
Je veux dire donc c'est des trucs en
l'air comme ça qui sont lancés mais qui
on des mais qui ont des effets de
répercussion. Par exemple, moi j'ai été
quand même très bouleversé. C'est un
pays que j'avais visité la Tunisie.
l'histoire là quand même que que le chef
d'état en Tunisie se permettent des
propos sur le grand remplacement au
point que des familles africaine
sont partis du jour au lendemain éta
obligé de retravailler au pays
après s'être fait tabasser
ou après c'est fait tabasser alors
meilleur des cas
perdre leur loyer perdre le truc
donc effectivement un propos
a a des effets a des effets.
Il faudrait faire une évaluation
psychiatrique des chefs d'état
régulièrement.
Ben, il y en a certains qui déraillent
effectivement. Enfin, c'est pas
psychiatrique mais à la limite on se dit
alors ils sont fait engueuler évidemment
par les États-fricains qui ont dit "Mais
qu'est-ce que vous racontez Mais bon,
une fois que le mal est une fois que
c'est dit,
moi je dois dire mais c'est savez moi
c'est un peu familial hein comme comme
je suis euh
donc ma famille était juif polonaise.
Bon et il faut pas oublier que les que
les juifs polonais l'pogrome c'était
c'était déjà la théorie du grand
remplacement. C'est-à-dire un jour ils
ont dit en Pologne ils sont trop
enfin les juifs étaient trop ils étaient
trop nombreux. Donc on l'a pas inventé
on l'a pas inventé là cette théorie. Et
dès que vous commencez à dire ça,
mécaniquement le problème est là. C'est
donc la psychologie des masses. Ça se ça
se met un jour à fonctionner.
C'est comme ça qu'on programme les
populations pour aller faire des
massacres.
Voilà, les génocides qu'on peut on
désigne en en et puis tout d'un coup ça
fonctionne, ça fonctionne. Il suffit de
toucher effectivement la langue presque
elle-même et un jour ça fonctionne un
tel, on lui donne un nom, un surnom, un
truc. Ah non, c'est c'est
donc voilà moi pour l'exil, je dirais
que ça c'est c'est il a aucune raison de
cesser. Ça fait pas de doute.
Il faudrait plutôt là c'est pareil avoir
une
un peu réfléchir collectivement, avoir
une politique
mais ça c'est du wishfuling.
Il faudrait c'est du wishful sinking.
Oui oui oui c'est bien c'est bien.
Il y a qu'un faucon. Moi moi je vais
vous donner une autre solution. Au lieu
de bombarder tout le monde, on remplace
les obus par des obus de cannabis. On
bombarde les populations au cannabis.
48h plus de guerre, hein.
C'est vrai.
Non, mais on n'est pas pour la promotion
du cannabis. Non non, je bien. C'est
vrai, c'est vrai. Non mais c'est vrai
qu'on C'est vrai que c'est pas il faut
il faut raison garder mais
le monde est en de toute façon le
on est on est une époque où le monde
change. Il est vrai, le monde bouge, ça
peut rendre craintif mais il ne sera
plus jamais comme on sait pas trop comme
en plus quand les gens disent comme
avant, il y a toujours eu des de toute
façon des phénomènes d'exil. Il y avait
les Italiens, les juifs, les ceci, les
cela portugais.
Portugais. Donc il y a jamais eu de
population au sens
enfin franco-française. Bon alors là ils
disent oui mais c'est eux ils sont ils
sont moins ils sont pas catholiques, ils
sont pas ceci, ils sont pas cela, ils
ont pas la même couleur, ils sont pas
bon c'est des arguments on est tout
petit peu étonné mais
vous parlez de couleur euh là on reçoit
on reçoit des réfugiés ukrainiens.
D'autres migrants qui étaient déjà là en
situation difficile bah se font un peu
pousser. Oui.
Comment ça se fait ça ?
Ah bah oui, c'est ça c'est ça qui est
bah les Ukrainiens ont ils ont eu tous
les droits tout de suite ce qui
d'ailleurs qui paraissait techniquement
impossible à faire. C'est-à-dire ils
auront donné tout en même temps à papier
les droits à logement les droits à
travail. Ce qui fait que le ministère
qui d'habitude met un an à répondre à
n'importe quelle question là presque en
en 48 he enfin l'état civil était donc
et sur les autres populations en
souffrance qu'est-ce que c'est Bah les
autres, ils les ont laissé, ils s'en
occupent. Bien sûr,
bien sûr. Donc ça ça aussi c'est bon.
Alors là, bon pareil, on peut
c'est l'hypocrisie sociale. Alors, on
peut pas faire peser ça sur les enfants
ukrainiens. C'est pas le bon évidemment
le mot qui est ukrainien à l'école, on
va pas lui dire on t'a pris à la place
d'un autre. C'est
parce que tu es blanc et tu es blond.
Oui, on peut pas dire ça mais sur le
message sociétal de de solidarité
à géométrie variable, ça ça pose des
questions. C'est vrai, moi j'ai mému,
enfin je peux vous le dire, c'est pas
très secret. Moi, j'ai m'émmu assez
bizarrement. Donc, les Ukrainiens, eux,
ils ont le passeport pour tout, mais moi
j'ai eu des Russes,
des Russes mais des vrais Russes qui eux
non, ils pouvaient passer au guichet des
Ukrainiens, ça marchait pas. Donc les
Russes se retrouvent eux dans la même
situation que l'Africain a demandé
l'asile. Ils sont pas plus c aédés.
Voilà la visarie d'administration
et les et les étudiants comme vous le
savez les parce que les Ukrainiens
avaient beaucoup d'étudiants étrangers
ou il
alors eux eux ont pas été traités comme
des Ukrainiens non plus. On a fait la
part entre l'Ukrainien de souche
et les étudiants black d'Afrique qui
étaient considérés comme Ah oui. Non
mais
comme des c'est ça c'était mais ça crée
des ça crée des
c'est quand même complètement dingue.
Ça crée des assidismes mental
incroyables. Bien sûr.
Bon qu'on peut pas faire reposer sur les
sur les sur les femmes sur les femmes
ukrainiennes et les enfants bien sûr
mais c'est un cylisme administratif.
Oui.
Question.
Comment vous voyez l'accompagnement en
terme l'accaparement pardon ? Comment
vous voyez l'accaparement en terme ?
J'ai plus vas-y l'écran vient de
s'éteindre. Je pose une autre question.
Que pense l'invité des algorithmes des
réseaux sociaux et de leurs effets les
bulles de filtre, le fait que les
algorithmes proposent toujours les mêmes
contenus ou renforcent l'opinion
toujours dans le même sens et ainsi de
suite. Vous vous êtes au courant de ça
ou
un peu comme ça ? Moi je suis pas très
très fort en
tout ce qui est tectique comme ça mais
je suis Oui, je suis au courant parle
mais ou les enfants ou par les
ou par les patients qui m'en parlent un
peu. Mais
c'est quoi ce petit cahier qui a sur vos
genoux là ?
Ah non non. Oui ça j'avais pris quelques
notes mais c'était juste pas
C'était quoi vos notes ? Bah, j'avais
fait, voyez, voici, je peux vous,
j'avais pris,
j'avais pris le vœu le vœu qu'on avait
eu au au tout débat.
J'avais dit le débordement parce que on
est un service de pédopsychiatrie qui
avait qui avion déjà assez de travail.
Donc, quand on a décidé de dire oui à la
demande
des sujets de l'exil, là, on s'est
trouvé tout de suite débordé.
Dans quelle proportion ?
Ah bah quand même, on quasiment chaque
semaine, on recevait des nouvelles
familles. Donc ça aussi c'est une
position qu'on a alors on l'a prise
collectivement, pas toute l'équipe, mais
suffisamment de l'équipe pour dire tout
à fait rien, on va être débordé.
Voilà, c'est
c'est une forme de sacrifice.
Alors moi, j'ai pas vécu ça comme un
sacrifice. Non, c'est ça qui est bien.
J'ai pas je leurais pas dit il faut se
sacrifier là.
J'is dire on va être débordé, faudra
faire mais remarquer comme un service
d'urgence éventuellement la nuit elle va
être débordée hein. Dit bon on est
médecin c'est les services peut être
débordés. Donc j'avais mis débordement
et on a pris la décision ça c'est comme
brche la décision là on a décidé de
recevoir ces enfants
quasiment sans délai. Alors, vous savez
que si vous appelez un service de
pédopsychiatrie à Paris aujourd'hui, ils
vont vous dire "Bah, venez avec votre
mom dans 6 mois, dans 8 mois." Est
toujours vivant.
Ouais. S'il est vivant, revenez. Bon, et
là,
c'est alors là, c'est on a pris la
décision paradoxale de dire pour pour
ces enfants-là,
on nous appelle, on les recevra la
semaine suivante. Ce qui a créé
pareillement une consid
comment vous faites ? On a dit "Bah on
va pas attendre
et tout ce qu'ils ont vécu déjà, on va
pas leur dire on vous accueille dans 8
mois, c'est pas possible ça."
C'est payé combien chef de service chez
vous,
hein ?
C'est payé combien chef de service chez
vous ?
Euh, chef de service pleintemps, bah ce
serait moi je suis pas pleintemps mais
ça devrait être au-dessus de environ
5000 € je pense.
Net, brut.
Non, net. Ouais.
Pour combien de d'heures de travailler
Mais là, c'est que pour les médecins.
Les autres catégories sont beaucoup
moins payées. Oui.
Non, les médecins, je dirais grosso modo
à mon goût sont assez bien payés. Les
médecins sont bien payés dès dès que
vous avez les catégories autres, les
psychologues, orthophonistes,
psychomotes et sans parler des
secrétaires, alors où on tombe, on tombe
beaucoup plus bas, ça va très vite.
Et donc voilà, j'avais dit ça
et recevoir sans attendre.
Deuxième injonction
presque religieux.
Voilà, presque religieux.
Et donc le slogan alors ça c'est alors
moi aussi des fois je fais des slogans
au lieu de faire un grand discours.
J'avais dit un jour à l'équipe on reçoit
le traumatisme bien sûr les
traumatismes, les deuils. Alors faire
attention, il y a beaucoup de deuil
hein. C'est des deuils et des
traumatismes en chassés. Est-ce que les
enfants la plupart sont enillés ? Ils
ont perdu leur père à la guerre, leurs
grands-parents, ils les reverront plus
leur maison, leur pays,
leur maison. Donc, il y a énormément de
comme disait Freud,
il faut relire le texte de Freud, d'œu
et mélancolie. Il y a des deuils deuil
et traumatisme mêlé, rechassé. Mais
j'avais dit à l'équipe, on va dire trop
mais pas tout le traumatis, on fait pas
que du traumatisme,
c'està-dire voyez, on n'est pas fixé
uniquement sans arrêt sur l'autre.
D'abord pour eux et pour nous, on peut
pas, on pourra pas vivre avec sinon.
Et donc il faut il faut recolorer la
vie, l'imaginaire. Il faut trouver les
moyens de remettre des fleurs, des
poèmes à l'endroit à l'endroit de tout
ça.
Pourquoi vous avez choisi des de faire
psi ?
Ah non, ça c'est au tout début
mais parce que dans ma pour des raisons
ici au tout début quand vous avez
commencer votre inter
moi j'ai commencé non non je voulais te
faire psy déjà j'étais
quand j'ai fait médecine je voulais déjà
être psy
mais ça c'est lié à des aux conditions
justement familiales les il y a eu il y
a eu des pathologies dans ma famille lié
à à ces effets d'exil là entre autres
et donc j'ai toujours eu dès l'enfance
pense eu affaire à des à des questions
qui touchaient la psychiatrie
et qui moi je pense que j'étais un bon
observateur, ça m'intéressait aussi.
Donc du coup donc j'ai fait médecine, je
savais à l'avance que je voulais me
faire de la psychologie.
Donc je me suis acquitté quand même de
mes études médicales parce que c'est
obligatoire.
J'étais pas j'étais pas très bon médecin
somaticien. C'était pas mon c'était pas
mon truc.
J'étais heureux quand je suis arrivé à
Saint-Ane à l'époque. Bien que ça changé
depuis.
Voilà. Donc ça reste non, j'ai pu j'ai
voilà reste
ça reste beau la psi bah c'est des
rencontres hein mais là mais là même
même les familles qu'on dit les exilés
les les évidemment c'est lourd par côté
mais les rencontres sont belles souvent
c'est-à-dire
on apprend on apprend des choses de leur
vie de leur pays de leur coutumes de
leur langue de leur on a eu des enfants
curdes vous savez les donc les curd de
syrien d'une fierté inouï
c'est une façon masquer leur faiblesse.
Euh Ah, ils étaient vraiment fiers de
Non, enfin les deux les deux. Mais alors
il nous récitait, ils chantaient des
poèmes, ils chantaient leurs chansons
traditionnelles, leur fêtes.
Il nous offrait souvent des
gourbandises. Enfin non, des fois des
fois des fois faites des rencontres,
c'est c'est même c'est même parfois
l'exilé qui vous qui vous ramène à
l'humanité en disant "Mais non, tu vas
tenir."
J'ai eu des on a des enfin je pourrais
en raconter en pagaille là, mais c'est
des une fois j'ai eu une petite enfin
c'est juste comme ça. Soyez pas timides,
on a le temps ici.
Voilà une petit J'ai toujours eu un
souvenir une un jour alors on reçoit,
c'est drôle, bah
une petite une petite palestinienne.
Donc elle avait un passeport
palestinien, elle venait d'Algérie parce
que les
était passé par l'Algérie,
ils vivaient en d'Algérie, c'est les
parents et cette fillette vivait
d'Algérie mais restait palestinien
comme dans beaucoup de pays arabes, il
est il regardait pour des raisons
politiques souvent par rapport à Israël,
le passeport palestinien, il était pas
devenu algérienne. Bon bref, pour une
raison que j'ignore, là c'est la
politique entre les États. La famille
s'en va un jour avec un sauvec conduit
donné par l'Égypte. Allez savoir
pourquoi. Donc ils arrivent à Roisé
sauf conduit égyptien
arrivent et donc ils sont ils sont le
gés là parement ils arrivent à Roissi
donc ils se retrouvent dans un centre
d'accueil pour les réfugiés demande
l'asile politique enfin pas politique
l'asile enfin l'asile tout court ce qui
a un cas rare parce que les Palestiniens
on les voit pas beaucoup arriver.
Alors cette fillette, je reçois cette
fillette,
on parle d'une petite he
enfin d'une vivacité.
Et alors je lui dis à quoi tu
t'intéresse
aux exoplanètes.
J'ai dit les exoplanètes. Caméraman
aussi il adore ça.
Non mais j'étais déjà étonné du terme
qu'elle
et alors
la semaine d'après, je lui amène une
petite revue scientifique là pour la
science junior là sur les exoplanètes.
Elle elle regarde ça, elle me dit "Oh
mais je connais déjà tout ça."
Et alors à propos de à propos de voyez
de fantasmagorie et joyeuseté et je lui
dis "Mais qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que tu
verrais faire plus tard ?" Et la petite
qui venait à peine d'arriver là en
France, elle me dit "Moi, je veux être
cosmonaute.
une détermination,
avec des yeux pétillants, une
intelligence
astronaute."
Voilà. astronaute.
Et alors bref, toujours est-il que ce
qui est fabuleux, c'est que cette
famille donc bon, ils ont eu de assez
vite le droit d'asile là, on était
reconnu et vous savez où ils les ont
envoyé comme je vous disais qu'il les
répartissait, ils ont été à Toulouse là
où il y a l'aérospatial là. Alors la
fille fillette lui dit "Bah voilà,
un jour je vais te voir à la télé.
Il y a peut-être un dieu sur terre. Il a
Dieu.
Alors c'est pour vous dire ça paraît ça
paraît mais ce genre de rencontre où
voyez où l'enfant pétill de vie et de
destinat, c'est-à-dire il se sent pas ni
sacrifié
ni
décidé que lui
la science des exoplanètes
l'intéressait. il voulait il et ça et ça
des rencontres comme ça on en fait plus
fréquemment qu'on ne le pense hein. Donc
il faut il faut balancer je dirais c'est
pour ça que ça ça me ça me rend quand
même pas trop triste, voyez de il y a
des tristesses, il y a des douleurs, il
y a des choses qu'on éponge en équipe,
on peut pas le faire seul. Et puis à
côté, on a des rencontres fabuleuses. On
a des on a des moments de joie, des
moments de remerciement,
des moments où on apprend, on apprend,
on apprend des exilés comment faire dans
un monde aussi dur. Effectivement, c'est
eux, ils savent ils savent mieux que
nous comment comment faire pour pour
tenir
le joueur d'échec qu'on cherchait tout à
l'heure c'était Casparov.
Ah voilà, c'est l'autre champion
Kasparov.
D'accord.
Question d'internet. Oh, je sais pas si
je vais vous la poser celle-là parce que
bon, pour faire le profil de quelqu'un,
il faut le pratiquer un peu, non ?
Pour faire le profil psychologique de
quelqu'un,
en principe.
En principe. Bon, si vous deviez dresser
le profil psychiatrique d'Emmanuel
Macron, vous lui diriez quoi ?
Je vous en pose une deuxième.
Oui.
Ou ou ou je vous laisse répondre à
celle-là.
Non, je dirais que Macron a un défaut
que tout le monde lui reconnaît, c'est
qu' il sait pas il est pas entouré de
conseiller.
Il c'est quelqu'un qui al ça peut
trouver un nom autour de évidemment de
stratégie de l'échec
autour de la question du narcissisme ou
des choses comme ça. Bon mais à la
limite ça n'apprend rien mais c'est
surtout qu'il il ne fait pas confiance.
Théoriquement les hommes d'état les
vrais hommes d'état sont entourés de
conseillers.
Il délègue
et d'abord il délègue et puis il y a des
choses où ils se font vraiment con ils
sont des vrais conseillers c'est-à-dire
des gens qui sont capables de par leur
présence dans des zones où l'homme
d'État ne sait pas. Il faut mieux qu'il
sache qu'il ne sache pas. lui à enfin
tout le monde dit qu'à l'évidence
personne ne le conseille ça
alors ça c'est quand même un symptôme.
C'est des bruits de couloir
euh Oui mais comme c'est répété beaucoup
puis comme on connaît pas Non mais moi
je connaissais
pour une raison là que je vais pas
développer là parce que c'est un peu de
la cuisine. On avait à l'époque de
l'ande on était passé par les
conseillers santé de on savait qui
joindre pour des à propos de l'autisme
vous savez des trucs polémiques. On
savait à qui s'adresser parmi les
conseillers, c'est-à-dire on pouvait
aller secrètement entre guillemets
donner des documents ou leur demander d'
et on savait que voilà, il savaient et
maintenant j'aurais même on sait même
pas qui on connaît même pas les on
connaît même pas le visage ou les noms
de gens qui qui seraient des des vrais
conseillers au sens complet. Donc je
dirais si si ça c'est vrai euh ça donne
l'idée d'un d'un personnage un peu trop
effectivement solitaire dans son
exercice. Ça fait pas de doute. Si c'est
vrai, à moins qu'il ait des conseillers
secrets
euh quelque part sous l'Élysée.
Question internet. Bonjour. Que
pensent-t-il du système de notation
citoyen chinois ?
C'est quoi ça ? Alors
le crédit social. En fait vous êtes
fliqué par toutes les caméras, je vous
résume trivialement. Vous traversez pas
euh vous traversez pas dans les clous,
vous avez tant de points en moins.
Vous remboursez pas votre crédit, vous
avez tant de points en moins. Il y a un
flic qui vous fait un PV, vous avez
moins.
Peut-être que si vous lisez le mauvais
livre, il vous avez des plans en moins.
Vous avez peut-être alors par contre si
vous lisez le bon livre, vous avez
peut-être des points en plus.
Le petit livre rouge.
Bon, ça vous connaissez pas ?
Non, pas trop. Non. Question question
internet, je prends la suivante tout de
suite à la ligne. Jean-Jacques
ou
quels seraient vos conseils de
selfdestance psychiatrique pour bien
vivre aujourd'hui dans ce monde où l'ego
a pris le dessus sur les communs moi
versus nous. Hm. Oui, c'est vrai. C'est
vrai. Bah et justement, je crois qu'il a
il donne la réponse en posant la
question, c'est-à-dire remettre remettre
du groupe humain. Remettre du groupe
humain. Quand quelqu'un pense uniquement
à partir de l'ego, il soit il est
totalitaire, soit il est fichu.
Et donc c'est le nous le pas le nous de
la foule ou de la masse, le nous le
groupe. le groupe humain, refaire
groupe. Là, je le disais tout à l'heure
dans mon dans mon service rien que pour
recevoir la charge là, on a fait groupe.
Aucun de nous n'a individ
Non, j'ai dit nous recevons en groupe.
Il faut qu'on tienne en groupe, qu'on
réfléchisse en groupe. Donc je dirais
que dans une dans une société où les
choses effectivement soit sont pensées à
un niveau de foule, soit sont pensées
sur un mode individualisme forcé, il
faut se réapproprier
ce qu'on appelle un groupe humain. Et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que moi là
c'est pas une question de psychiatre.
Moi comme citoyen, je pense qu'il faut
pas maltraiter les syndicats par
exemple. C'est ça fait partie des enf ce
qu'on appelle les corps intermédiaires
dans le temps.
Et donc c'est il faut être il faut être
fou pour maltraiter les corps
intermédiaires
parce que quand on commence comme ça
dans l'entreprise dans la partout mais
c'est un exemple d'un vrai groupe
un un syndicat c'est pas une foule c'est
pas vrai. C'est un groupe humain.
Question internet. Dépression et
psychotrauma sont-ils contagieux ?
C'est pas bête comme question. Oui, ça
peut ça peut avoir un aspect épidémique.
Oui, c'est pas faux.
C'est pas faux. On se demande par
exemple en en Iran là, vous avez vu où
il y a des espèces de de
traumas dans les enfin collectifs dans
les écoles dans les
C'est pas des traumas, c'est il y a des
gamines qui sont
voilà. Mais si vous partez d'un exemple
comme ça euh qui est dupliqué,
au bout d'un temps, il y a un côté
épidémique au som. Effectivement, on
peut on peut créer un espèce d'épidémie
traumatique,
mais là, je saurais pas dire pour
l'Iran, j'eni aucune idée, hein.
Ouais, il y a des empoisonnement en Iran
là.
Voilà, c'est un exemple. C'est un
exemple. Et des fois si vous créez
une folie comme ça quelque part, on
s'aperçoit que tout d'un coup, on sait
plus et puis après on sait pas si si
c'est c'est généralisé comme fête ou
bien comme épidémie traumatisée. quand
quand on voit le monde à l'heure
actuelle avec euh
des révoltes, des gens qui se sont tapés
dessus, des guerres, des famines, des
des mouvements de population qui
essayent de survivre, des des gamins qui
crèvent dans la Méditerranée
et même ailleurs, euh on n' pas
l'impression que notre élite notre élite
a pris le contrôle de l'asile de fou. On
n pas l'impression que les fous ont pris
le contrôle de l'asile. Est-ce que c'est
pas devenu un asile à ciel ouvert sans
sans vouloir être péjoratif avec les
asiles ?
Est-ce que est-ce que là ça devient
complètement surréaliste ? Là
c'est il y a il y a une type de folie
mais qui est une folie
qu'il faudrait caractériserait trouver
un nom nouveau pour ces foliesl. C'est
pas les folies psychiatriques
habituelles, je dirais. Donc elles sont
plus graves presque parce que comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure, le fou pour
moi a sa dignité. Il parle pas comme
nous parlons nous. Il n'a pas la
rationalité qu'on
il vit d'autres formes du réel. C'est
c'est à respecter, c'est à essayer de
tandis que là ce que vous désignez c'est
des c'est des folies
c'est c'est des folies qui à la limite
elles passent parce qu'elles n'ont pas
encore de nom. Faudrait leur donner des
noms, trouver un nom. Une fois qu'elles
seront nommées, peut-être que ça
permettrait d'ailleurs de les distancier
un peu.
Et donc ça paraît le terme de ce qui
nous piège, c'est le qu'on a pas
beaucoup de mots en français fou folie
fou.
Question internet. Que pens que pense
l'invité du manque de considération de
l'aspect psychologique dans le travail
en France ? Je pense dans un alors
attends,
je travaille dans un centre d'appel et
ayant fait une année de psychologie à la
fac, je vois mes collègues devenir des
zombies, voire pour certains fous dès
qu'ils entendent une sonnerie de
téléphone tellement notre travail
ressemble à du travail à la chaîne.
Bah oui, c'est Charlot dans le c'est
Charlie Chapelin de vous rappeler
le bip les téléphones ainsi de suite.
des gens qui se font réveiller par le
bip de scanner un article ou des choses
comme ça.
Non non mais le monde du travail B c'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu tout toute cette
vague de enfin ce qu'on appelle à Tor
raison le burnout c'est pareil.
Pourquoi Thor Warison ?
Bah je dirais c'est c'est le risque
c'est de mettre sous un mot unique des
effectivement des défenses variées.
On appelle ça. Alors du coup c'est
toujours embêtant quand il y a un seul
mot pour décrire des réalités de
souffrance au travail.
C'est comme on dit l'autisme au
singulier alors que c'est un syndrome.
Euh c'est si vous dites la psychose ça
n'a aucun sens. Il y a plusieurs formes
de psycho. Enfin bref, moi tout ce qui
est singulier comme ça, je me dis bon
c'est réducteur. Du coup, on croit qu'on
prend des un travailleur qui est là
c'est un exemple, ça peut on peut en
trouver d'autres qui sont qui seront
différents fin de maltraitance au
travail.
Par contre que le les entreprises
actuellement elles font semblant de
s'occuper, elles sont obligées. Enfin,
légalement, il y a des commissions.
Mais il est vrai que bizarrement ça n'a
ça surenché assez curieusement, ça ne
fait que surenchérir. C'est-à-dire
l'automaticité des tâches,
le fait qu'on voit jamais les
directions, tout se fait par mailing,
ceci, cela moi. Donc
les gens se font virer par mail.
Les gens se font virer. Oui. Voilà. on
peut se faire virer sans même savoir euh
par qui. Donc il y a des curiosités
comme ça qui s'accélèrent alors même
qu'en principe il est dit qu'on devrait
faire plus attention aux souffrances dit
au travail. C'est vrai que c'est c'est
un paradoxe. Un paradoxe comme quoi le
fait de désigner parfois un symptôme ne
fait que le renforcer. Effectivement.
Est-ce que vous voulez parler de quelque
chose en particulier ? En plus
on a fait un bon tour là déjà. Est-ce
que vous avez trois trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Ah, trois livres à conseiller. Bah, j'en
ai cité, je crois un moi. Alors, puisque
vous me posez la question, je crois qu'
il faut dire aux jeunes, au moins
jeunes, mais
actuellement euh moi j'ai des livres de
chevet
freudien bien sûr, mais il faut pas
c'est pas réservé au psychanalyste hein.
Un jeune aujourd'hui si s'il lit
Pourquoi la guerre ? Freud a écrit un
texte pourquoi la guerre par exemple.
avec Einstein a écrit l'autre texte.
Pourquoi la guerre ? Il faut le lire.
Deuil et mélancolie, il faut le lire.
C'est des c'est des comètes universel.
C'est fabuleux.
Et ça, je conseillerais aux jeunes
aujourd'hui de d'aller puiser dans la
Est-ce que oubliez pas Freud savez à
quelle époque il vivait hein. Faut aller
voir ce que c'était que la Vienne hein.
On est dans Vienne et qu'elle est
devenir ce que ça va devenir.
Et néanmoins, il élabore, il travaille,
il reçoit, il écrit et il faut lire. Je
dirais ça c'est alors peut-être un autre
auteur qui me vient qui me revient en ce
moment très fort c'est Kafka.
C'est très cfkaen en ce moment.
Ouais. Ouais. Kafka. Donc moi je dirais
aller tout de suite à la métamorphose
par exemple d'autres textes, aller
relire parce que Kafka est resté pour
les il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
de grands philosophes qui ont dit que il
revenait à Kafka qui avait la capacité
de raconter ce rapport à l'autre si
difficile si difficultulteux
et on est on est comme on est en pleine
métamorphose effectivement sociale.
C'est vraiment une façon une façon
d'attraper sur un mode disons plus
poétique toutes les difficultés dont on
a parlé. Alors troisème terme alors moi
c'est ça c'est grâce à mon père quand
j'étais jeune. Il il m'a obligé à lire
les enfin les grands auteurs russes.
Lesquels ?
Ah bah tous les grands Tous les grands
que vous connaissez là
en français ou en russe ?
Non non en français. les grands auteurs
russes traduit. Mais parce que non, je
crois que parce que l'âme l'âme russe
pour reprendre ce terme les grands parce
que on dit on dit je crois que c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas il y a pas plus haute
littérature quasiment que les grands
auteurs russes. Et c'est pour dire que
un peuple un peuple c'est pas simplement
le peuple en guerre là qu'on voit où
l'armée russe. Il y a un peuple, il y a
une âme, il y a des grands très grands
auteurs russes et peut-être peut-être de
dire oubliez pas qu'un jour on pourra on
pourra revivre en commun et peut-être
apprécier à nouveau un certain nombre de
choses communes. Voilà, peut-être
si si on se vitrifay pas tous la gueule
à coup de bombe nucléaire.
Voilà,
je vais j'ai j'ai si on est encore là.
J'ai été piégé par ma communauté, je
vais être obligé de vous poser une
dernière question.
Et euh et après je vous demanderai un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Ouais.
Euh le docteur Tisler a-t-il un
commentaire sur cette citation à tribuné
à Anna Harent ? Alors attention un peu
de lecture. Oui mais j'aime bien Arent.
Oui.
Quand tout le monde vous ment en
permanence le résultat n'est pas que
vous croyez ces mensonges mais que plus
personne ne croit plus en rien. Un
peuple qui ne peut plus rien croire ne
peut se faire une opinion. Il est privé
non seulement de sa capacité d'agir,
mais aussi de sa capacité à penser et de
juger. Et avec un tel peuple, vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez.
C'est vrai non ? Rent, moi j'aime bien
Rent à part bon évidemment il y a
désordre avec des guerres mais ça sur
les ça de côté
Arent elle est c'est une voyante à sa
façon et c'est pour ça que la question
de les
bah c'est pour ça qu'on avait parlé tout
à l'heure de la question de les moi je
dis pas de la croyance mais des
croyances voyez c'està-dire accepter que
il nous faille néanmoins une petite
utopie en nous effectivement
au sens au sens classique, pas l'utopie
mais au sens il faut il faut accepter
que
il y a foi comment dire en une petite
utopie une croyance. Oui. Un peuple qui
n'a plus aucune utopie au sens classique
il est il est désespéré devient
nilidiste.
Vous connaissez la fin du poème du
renoncement de Saint-Pierre.
Je sortirai de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas sort du rêve.
Moi je
Un rêve. Un rêve.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Vous en avez un autre quelque chose ?
Bah le
moi le conseil que je donne
ordinairement
bah le même que je donne aux enfants que
je reçois, je leur dis quoi que disent
l'école sur le fait qu'il soit mauvais
en ceci, pas bon en cela. Quoi que
disent les parents qui sont tout le
temps à les observer pour queils soient
meilleurs. Quoi qu'on dise d'eux, je
leur dis mais non, vous avez forcément
quelque part un talent. C'est
obligatoire.
Ça n'existe pas quelqu'un qui n'a pas un
très particulier talent. C'est obligé.
et je leur dis, c'est pas moi qui vais
vous le c'est pas moi qui vais le
désigner, mais nous allons faire en
sorte de de le voir surgir.
Et donc et donc
c'est pour vous donner un exemple hein,
mais c'est tout bête comme nous on
travaille beaucoup sur le dessin dans
mais je suis étonné que chaque année je
tombe sur des enfants qui ont un trait
de dessin mais au sens propre inoui.
C'estàd ça va être les futurs enfin
dessinateurs dont on a besoin
maintenant.
Maintenant on a on a des intelligences
artificielles, faut faire non mais je
veux dire par là hein mais on peut pas
on peut pas deviner quand on les reçoit
comme ça à la louche. Mais donc mais ce
n'est qu'un exemple donc je dirais aux
jeunes génération croyez qu'il y a
forcément un trait distinctif le vôtre
qu'il faut faire surgir. Voilà
Jean-Jacques Tisler merci. Je vous
remercie aussi.
[Musique]